welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
chess.com
junior speed chess championship we have
an amazing match
uh for you guys today between grand
masters nihal saren
and andrew tang i'm grandmaster daniel
nerdisky and it is my pleasure to be
commenting today with uh feed a master
my client mike how has your morning been
are you as excited as i am for this
match
yeah i don't know how i got chosen for
what i think is going to be the most
exciting opening round match
uh so i hope to not disappoint but i
would have watched this one as a fan
anyway
which means i would not have been
productive so i guess my bosses figured
they might as well hire me so
the number one seed against the top ko
qualifier i couldn't ask for much more
absolutely well we all know you're
awesome mike so i think we all know why
we're chosen well
before we jump into the action let's
take a quick look at the bracket and
i am going to force you to make some
predictions
because you are the uh nominated
nostradamus so we have just so many
mouth-watering names uh mike anything
catches your eye from
these first rounds any particular
players that you think we should watch
uh well what captured my eye was
actually the country of origin of the
players we've got five indians
three americans two russians and two
iranians that's kind of a different
balance of power
than i might have expected unfortunately
for the two russians they seem to be
playing each other
now as far as predictions i'm a little
bit hesitant because uh
you know first of all i want to look
silly but also if there's one thing they
teach you in journalism school
it's you know try to keep your
impartiality so can i let you know in
three hours who's a favorite in this
match is that okay
that's fine but i think uh we already
have a
model that is ready so it is too late
uh that's true this is a statistical
model but as you can see
um we've got uh well the number one seed
is actually
seemingly going to be the favorite
statistic i can't believe that
can you believe the number way let me
get that straight a number once you
but we have nihal sarah he is of course
an absolute beast but we will get into
that
but all of these other names i mean
martha rose and muksud lou
they are not only amazing chess players
but blitz and bullet
juggernauts so i mean this is just gonna
this is obviously going to be very very
close so this yeah
take a look at it the one of the
predictions is for savion to get to the
finals
i'm not sure sevion gets past the first
round um
that's kind of i think that's one of the
nice things about the junior speed chess
championship
not that the regular speed chess
championship is not worth watching but
one versus 16 matchups in the regular
speed chess championship
are usually just magnus toying with
somebody ricardo twins
right exactly but we will be incredible
yeah well let's take a quick look at the
format and some of the logistics so
everyone is on board we have of course
16 players
uh each match consists of three hours
yeah and we have a 90 minute segment of
five plus one as with most speed chess
championship matches 60 minutes of three
plus one and thirty minutes of bullet
everything played with a one second
increments
um and that is pretty much standard
uh standard fare yeah like any
thoughts about that well the increment i
think uh
probably negatively uh affects tang
because
tang plays hyper bullet in fact is there
something called ultra bullet
i just had to learn what the term was
for 15 second chess
i mean 30 second chess is already a bit
of a weird thing but
peng is probably negatively impacted by
that but sarna is also so fast as well
i wonder could we allow the players to
mutually agree to abandon the one second
increment if they both so choose
i i think neither will be against it to
be completely honest with you mike yeah
they're so incredibly fast both of them
in their own way
and you know people might be a little
bit more familiar with andrew's speed
but but nihal is
well as of a couple of days ago he was
number one on chess.com bullet with
over 3200 i shudder to think what his
rating is now with the update uh so he
is
and i've played him many times myself
he's incredibly strong
uh so so this is actually going to be
very very close and we
are about to have liftoff here any
second now not to say the five minute
section is going to be boring
they're also both very very strong
players mike
yeah in fact nihal was a mere fm a
couple of years ago when i interviewed
him at the isle of man tournament
and everybody was saying you know prague
was getting a lot of attention but
everybody was saying keep your eye on
nihal
and i'm a historically horrible judge of
talent but those people of course were
not wrong
he didn't actually beat his first gm
until four years ago
which is a little strange to you know
wait till you're 12 years old to be your
first gm over the board
but of course now he is one himself he
is the number one seed
in the tournament i'm curious donya is
he the number one classically rated
player as well
i know he's the number one seed that's
based on some some blitz and bullet
ratings right
and by the way we do now have liftoff
and i actually think
is max lou maybe higher a little bit
higher than what what exactly is nihal's
feed
is he over 26.50 as we have a very
fashionable line of the queen's camera
here on the board
i'll look that up for you but since
we're right into the action we will get
popular stuff nowadays yeah do you think
uh players a little more conservative in
the opening round matches i mean the
fact that
white has already gotten rid of the
tension with c4 c5
is it uh is it like the worst thing in
the world to lose your first game as
white and that's why you might see this
move
it definitely i mean i've noticed this
commentating a lot of these matches
uh there is this you know you begin
conservative you definitely don't want
to jump out to a
three zero four zero deficit that is
crushing and so we see
knee hall is a jack of all trades i've
seen him play literally everything under
the sun
and that i think is a hallmark mic of
young players these days they used to
have a narrow repertoire i remember when
i was growing up
i was only playing one opening nowadays
they're playing everything and
they're playing everything at an
increasingly young age i
kind of like white's position here in
the early going with this pawn on c6
being as strong as it is vikings could
consider just bishop d395
something tells me this is still theory
and i'm completely out of date but i do
like what nihal is doing here
i hope we get different openings you
know i just got done in july
being the commentator for the chess kid
youth speed chess championship 10 years
and younger
and those kids would get trained on one
opening and play it for three hours well
actually the match is only two
um and nothing against them they're
going to have more limited repertoires
when they're 10. so
the nice thing is today when they play
an opening that i know nothing about i
probably won't see it again so i only
have to be stupid for five minutes
yeah i actually wonder if it's going to
be one of those matches where they play
the same thing
every single game uh or or they vary so
andrew settling into a thing here um
he's got some problems to solve the
spawn on c6 is like a splinter in
black's position
one thing to consider here would be
bishop a6 trying to lighten the level
he goes a4 so he limits white's ability
to push his pawns on the queen side now
bishop b5 here mike
that looks pretty scary to me i maybe
andrew wants to meet it with something
like bishop a6
um something to this effect but
then white can just capture on a4 the id
bishop a6 being to stop white from
castling but
this definitely doesn't work right off
the bat i'm not seeing anything wrong
with bishop b5
yeah i think the reason black played a4
was because if b4 was allowed to happen
and then the pawn got to b5 as well
if black could never accomplish the e5
break black's playing without a piece
so you're exactly a4 to be able to take
on poisson
to always at least be able to trade
bishops on a6 at the very least
yeah and as i'm thinking about this it
occurs to me that maybe
what does known bishop oh bishop b2 that
was a mouse slipped by me i think this
should be five rook a5 maybe
with that same idea bishop takes a4
bishop a6 i'm trying to stop away from
castling but here look at this rogue on
a5 it gets snapped off by that pawn
so maybe nihal trying to figure out what
is wrong with bishop e5 but
andrew is such a tricky player he
usually has something in mind
yeah now if you play bishop b5 and then
you get your queen onto the same
diagonal then
essentially what you're trying to do is
play an entire game based on one bad
piece and to
borrow a phrase from grand master sam
palatnik
the bishop on c8 and i apologize for the
first russian accent
is a thick buffalo and when you have a
sick
buffalo it makes the whole herd sick
um i don't mean to get too close to our
our present pandemic this is something
was saying well before the coronavirus
but uh when you make one piece bad it
can often ruin an entire position and
this is going to inhibit all of black's
development if the bishop on ca doesn't
find a home
no i mean your russian accent was very
good mike i approve
very much yes okay but okay what does uh
android
do in this position because it takes a
fourth yeah i mean
the question is really maybe black
doesn't do anything and he
waits for white to take on a4 and then
goes bishop basics and again stops
tries to prevent white from castling
that seems to me to be the only thing
that
black can do to compensate maybe some
like 98 try to get this knight to d6 now
this
this does not look good to me and some
something definitely has gone wrong here
in the opening for andrew as he is
burning into his clock
using up almost half of it now by move
13.
and what i would ask you is does white
even want the pawn or does white just
want to control the diagonal leading to
a6
um i think he just wants to control that
diagonal i mean and the thing is
the terrifying thing is white will not
even have to rush taking on a4
as you say you can castle first and
lessen the impact of black's control
over that diagonal
i mean is black just lost here i i'm
just struggling to understand
you know what what uh andrew can even do
here
you know what's funny donya uh it's time
for me to record my next chess kid video
and there's not many topics i haven't
covered yet but
wedge pawns is a topic i've not covered
and i'm just going to take a little note
about this position because i need
fodder for my videos and i think that c6
pawn counts as a wedge
fun very interesting that's one of those
concepts mike that's not often talked
about but
can be the secret sauce in a lot of
positions i like it
um i approve not that anybody cares but
but i approve the video
uh so here we have a5 andrew settling on
it nihal again trying to figure out is
anything wrong with just taking the pawn
um maybe andrew can try to liberate his
position a little bit with b5 and b4
uh and if you take on b4 well then i
take with check and then i can play that
favorite move of ours bishop a6
so maybe that's the idea and nihal
definitely there's some
he takes and we have b5 so
the thing is white can drop his bishop
back in castle and give
back the extra bond that is also
something to consider
let's see what new when he all does here
i wonder if bishop b3 b4 if white plays
a4 and just says i'm going to try to win
every end game that ever existed but he
still loses control of the diagonal
no i love that though because maybe now
you can swing your knight around to d3
use the knight as a
blockader and then castle not that it's
that important to castle
it's not like black has a raging attack
here but we have some
action yeah we have bishop c2 before you
could still go a4
and redirect the bishop to d3 but you'd
have to be careful about not losing the
a4 pawn in that case
so some problems to solve for sure for
nihal um
a4 bishop a6 and then again he's not in
a big hurry so maybe he doesn't even
need to
castle that quickly funny comment in the
chat nihal may be sleepy it is hard to
accommodate a time
that works for both the central u.s time
zone and the indian time zone so
i don't think it's that late in india
though although that is one piece of
intel that i did not do before the match
it looks like it's about 9
30 in india um so i don't know nihal's
sleep schedule i don't think that's too
late for most 16 no
no no i don't think so i think this is
when he starts his his blitz sessions on
chess.com but i
speaking of the times i always had this
problem with my chess coaches because
they were always in europe
somewhere in europe and so it was
usually at my morning and their evening
let's just say i'm not a morning person
and let's just say i had some angry
coaches
i'll share some stories later mike but
that was never fun for me
even as a kid well
knee hall dipping by the way below a
minute almost
yeah i do like what black has done here
because if there's one thing i've
learned about playing strong grand
masters is that
you can't allow them every trump in the
position you have to do something to
free your position so
the fact that black is offered upon to
get activity is a no-brainer you just
can't allow yourself
to get overwhelmed slowly yeah you
simply cannot
be bite in your time you have to do
something now
um if white goes a4 i think when what is
changed my mouse this has been happening
now in my bullet games and bla
white ghost b3 maybe what nihal's
worried about is this knight swinging
over to c3
i'm not sure that's truly something to
worry about
but maybe nihal is trying to you know
not allow any kind of counter play
and he does end up castling so something
he didn't like there now i still think
he's better mike
as you mentioned this wedge pawn
definitely gives him an advantage
there's no doubt in my mind about that
yeah probably easier though to give the
pawn back and play this position with 40
seconds left
rather than having to worry about okay
when the knight comes to c3
you know how do i uh manage my position
so
maybe he just bailed out and said i
can't be worse in this position i can
play it more quickly
with 40 seconds left right and now
another decision for andrew which
pawn which piece does he take the pawn
with um
if you take with the bishop you might
get pinned so from that perspective
maybe you take the rook now not that
that pin is so scary
um maybe you go after this maybe you
play bishop a6 first and try to gain a
tempo that does seem pretty reasonable
i'm not sure i love nihal's decision to
be honest of giving this pawn back
and here we do have bishop a6 bishop d3
white is always going to be better in
end games because of this pawn
but with every trade it seems to me that
the load on
black's position is less than like yeah
now the c7 pawn is starting to become a
thought in white's idea and of course
the c7 pawn is basically the game
because if you get a pawn on c6 that's
unrivaled it's going to be hard to stop
right completely agree um maybe yeah so
maybe 95 queen v7 here for white
this is going to be a time scramble they
are both now at 30.
seconds and is this a surprise to anyone
and the increment though mike is going
to
introduce definite nuance into these
time scrubs as we've seen before
by the way if we were to reconstruct
this match as a straight up one minute
bullet match no increment
would tang be a going away favorite or
you know he's so much more well known
than sauron
but it's i think you know a little bit
more about nihal skills so
uh they do have an increment but in a
pretend world where they don't who would
be the favorite
i would have to go with andrew now take
this with a grain of salt it's so close
they're both so incredibly strong
but to me andrew seems just a little bit
more experienced in those time scrambles
and a little bit faster
and i think that would impact positively
now here we see neat hall 10 seconds to
19 from andrew
so let's watch as this game uh comes to
its conclusion we have andrew activating
his pieces rook c3 to be considered
there is queen's
queen tension and nihal grabs the queen
now he can try to go after the c pawn
with rook b7
he's got seven seconds this is where the
respective internet service providers
um start to get a little bit nervous
g5 okay do we have a fizzling out here
again i think white's better mike you
can go knight c5
two seconds gotta make a move though oh
this is actually wondering if you could
play rook b7 there as an ex
as a sacrifice because it was hard to
guard the c7 pawn but i don't think it
was worth the risk
maybe knight d7 too knight b7 also that
b7 square i like that idea but he's
doubling on the b-file
maybe he's preparing that sacrifice
three seconds and we're going nicely for
going after the pawn
rook b7 now rookie in two seconds of the
clock he's won the pawn videos knight
takes c6
e4 definitely knee hall pushing here
this is so hard to play for andrew
rookie somebody's trying to hunker down
knight coming around to b4 what is going
on here
andrew trying to hold this together d5
looks like it's going down
it is but now he's going to go rook a2
rook d7 checking rook g1 though
oh he pre-moved badly now takes some
geeky seven he didn't expect that wasn't
the worst free move in the world
definitely not i've seen worse but this
might be a draw now now andrew's the one
pushing he's got the active rook
he has got the act of broke now nehal
has to be careful
with one second second on the clock but
this should be a draw mike rick on e5
and we have fizzle out here in a draw
yeah and let's see if they agree to it
if they try to blitz each other with a
one second increment doesn't make much
sense
right blitz each other exactly and we
have
peace it appears well king f7 would not
make make sense that would blunder the
pun with check we have a draw in the
first game
and wow it seems to me that
nihal definitely had that opportunity in
the opening maybe that
idea to castle was a little bit on the
conservative side and
didn't make the most out of the
advantage but you know nothing
disastrous for
for him obviously yeah and not so bad
for white you know you pushed you pushed
you were the aggressor
but you got a little short on time and
you bailed out and uh
i think it was it was a managed game it
wasn't
a game where white took undue risks
right i i completely agree um and it's
so early in the match here we have
a nimzo indian with andrew's queen c2
now i brought this up
in the uh qualifiers andrew is
someone who and we discussed this with
nihal but andrew always plays the same
stuff he plays his classical repertoire
even in blitz and bullet which has its
positives and negatives
he knows it very well but it is easy to
prepare against including this queen c2
nimzo
he plays this exclusively he's played it
against me a million times
and nihal choosing an interesting line
where his queen has come out to f5
again we have a pawn on a4 that pawn is
weak if you bring the bishop back
white could consider snagging it but
white's king's side is undeveloped so
this looks like a pretty sharp position
in a decision to be made now by nihal
and i was listening to your broadcast
with robert hess on the
qualifier on the knockout qualifier
where you said that some players prepare
heavily for these online blitz matches
and some kind of don't they just you
know they may have a loose idea what
they want to do
i don't take knee hall as being a wing
it tight player
i take knee hall as being a player who
probably did
heavily invest some time into andrew's
limited opening repertoire
um and come up with some systems he
wanted to play against it
yeah definitely he he's very methodical
he plays
you know well-prepared stuff but
at the end of the day you know andrew's
ex
just extremely deep knowledge of his
lines might come in handy so we see
bishop d6 played
and now a decision to be made by ander
does he take the point i would say no
because of knight e4 this just seems
a little bit fishy to me um
maybe you just go e3 and then bishop d3
and i feel like white is probably
slightly better here i mean honestly
with the possibility of going e4
black on the other hand he can try to
break through on his own with e5 so
we'll see how this hap how this um i
think i see why this fails
uh but can you tell the fans why e4
knight takes e4 bishop d3 does not work
although it looks tempting i think
there's a
foil but maybe you can show everybody
what that is absolutely uh but before i
do
a quick reminder of the schedule as we
work on a very quick uh
technical fix uh it seems that there is
a bit of an issue with the evolve bar so
we'll remove it for now we apologize
uh but just to remind people right now
is of course uh the beginning of the
main bracket which lasts almost a month
to october 5th
uh and the final is on october 8th at
9am pacific so
capture that day in your calendars right
now um because it is going to be
what whoever is going to be playing like
it's going to be epic as we already see
from this match and we have
action heating up in this game we
apologize for the
technical glitch i'm not sure what the
what the issue is but
hopefully you'll have to put your trust
in the hands of me
and and mike i i know that's terrible
but we have to ask for your
understanding
you are the eval bar my friend well i
appreciate i'm not sure everybody in
chat shares that belief but
i've been playing decently the last
couple of days so give me a chance give
me a chance
um okay so we have wow we have queen c2
on the board the queen hunting for this
pawn but wait a minute is that queen
going to get in trouble
there's one line i see e3 takes rook b1
and if the queen starts lining its
pockets you have knight b5 and the queen
is trapped
so the hall is playing with fire here
what does he want after e3 maybe knight
a5
involving the knight not sure definite
stuff to calculate here for andrew
and andrew has gone queen a2
yeah the b-pawn is the classic poisoned
pawn but there must have been something
he didn't like about allowing the queen
to capture it because you're putting
your queen
in an awfully defensive spot and you're
relieving black of any need to ever
guard the a4 pawn
that's exactly right um so it's kind of
a moral victory there for neal does he
go e5 now
this might be the window of opportunity
but whoa mike after rook c1 queen g6
white can go knight h4 and the queen of
straps like yeah on g6
so still he's got to be careful so maybe
he goes queen b3 there
but then we might have the case of a
weak pawn or another wedge on v3 so the
hull's definitely calculated i can
guarantee he's calculating e5 right now
there are alternatives he can well are
there alternatives i don't know maybe
94.
very very sharp position here and i
would expect them to labor out of the
opening because
you know people often say chess players
are great at pattern recognition but
only patterns that we know of
there aren't very many games your
queen's on a2 there's a black queen on
c2
where she can get trapped on different
wings of the board there's a pawn on g4
so just like i'm struggling to come up
with familiar patterns in this position
yeah the players are probably needing to
make sure too because these queen traps
are coming out of nowhere
they really are and you bring up a great
point which is the more unconventional
the position the harder it is to
to detect these things the more thinking
time is required as we see again
by move 13 uh knee hall has dipped
below half of his time used and andrew
also two minutes 44 seconds so
a lot to think about here in the opening
now i'm looking at this position i'm
wondering what else there is other than
e5 this move knight e4
the point is after rook c1 you can take
the knight on c3 counter attacking
white's queen
you can't take back with a pawn because
of the pin you can't take with a bishop
because the rook is hanging so white
does drop a piece here
so this might be one way to ensure
better queen
safety uh but it comes at the cost of
not liberating that bishop
and we have knight a5 so nihal choosing
to direct his knight to b3 or is he
securing
potentially that square for his queen
roxy one now will force queen b3
but i've got a new best friend user b
handleman in the chess.com tv chat says
i trust mike not sure about donya
i'm not sure about your
honesty there but uh somebody's looking
for some sort of premium membership that
i'm not giving away but you got your
name announced on air that's probably
what you're going for
that yeah you
you sniff that right out so we have
e3 now so we have again the tension
between the queens does
you all capture the queen i don't think
there's any need to do that immediately
yeah as we see him just developing
bishop comes i quite like what he's
that bishop is not going to come to b6 i
quite like what he's chosen here
uh directing that bishop to c6 to the
long diagonal
um mike your early recommendation of
going e4
i kind of like that more i feel like
black is getting the upper hand gear
uh bit by bit yeah i'm just not used to
positions where your pawns on g4
and i'm trying to figure out how that
relates to my evaluation of the position
i could even see a situation where white
plays queen b1
intentionally avoiding the trade because
the black queen is going to be
vulnerable in some ways when the light
squared bishop finds activity
um i'm not sure if we'll find a third
way to trap the black queen one day
but uh it could happen maybe i'd be
three but i've shown a sample line
definitely we could see a way that this
could backfire
um but yeah this might be the best that
white can do
now andrew with with one minute that is
just going to be the narrative
we're going to see a lot of time
scrambles in this match there's no doubt
about that
yeah i'm guessing also dona both players
are more comfortable draining their
clock down to 30 seconds
because of their but their skills and
their experience playing
games that have less than one minute to
start the time
yeah they're they're just so used to it
and um is it sort of a compulsion to do
it i think at some point
there is a certain rush and i can attest
to that that comes
with not having any time by move 16 and
playing on increment that there is a
certain adrenaline rush that that
awakens in you um not that you do it
deliberately but you know
there might be a little bit of that at
play yeah but you know
we all have friends in life that always
seem to be the ones that get themselves
into dramatic situations
and at some point you're like this
person is seeking out the drama
and so that is so true
that is very true and we have bishop
coming to c6 as we expect
now probably castles to be expected here
from penguin
um and when i say penguin he is so known
by that moniker now i feel
very comfortable just saying that it
doesn't sound weird
um that's what he's always been by the
way how does tatev feel about
the number one penguin being andrew
because you know tata's got a big
attachment to the penguin name as well
that is true now that i think about it
well i don't know
if we bring in todd and we've got to
bring my brother he's a big fan of
penguins as well
i'm sure he's watching the broadcast
right now he is terribly offended
but uh you know we got to give andrew
some credit he is after all
a wizard but he is in trouble here 25
seconds look at nihal laying it on now
knight c4 threatening the v21 now if you
take on c4 you're going to have big
problems with this knight on f3
so that's out of the question and we
have knight to d1 bringing the knight
back now andrew trying his best to ward
off this attack yeah
d2 you have to take with the king or can
you take with the knight you can't take
with a knight because you hit the queen
and then people move now black is still
doing fine here
but i wouldn't do that if i were knee
hell i would try to find a way to keep
this knight on c4 maybe go b5 but then
we might have that third wave of traffic
this time on d5 on b3 it might escape to
d5
but then you have bishop f3 and with the
bishop amazing
what if the knight takes d2 knight takes
and the queen relocates to d5 not
b6 like a more active square but then
you still might have that bishop f3 move
got it yeah and then you might root out
that bishop so
i don't see exactly a good move for new
hall here and apparently neither does he
because he now has depth below
30 seconds and maybe the best that he
can do is in fact do to take on b2 drop
the queen back
and save some time he's taken on f3
which does make sense because if bishop
takes f3 he can force white's king out
to d2
uh which is something you hit on mike
but we have now e5 so he's opening up
the center trying to exploit the
weakness of this gang
ten seconds out for andrew and buckle
your seat belts we have another time
scramble on our hands
yeah white needs to find a safe file for
the king i'm not sure which one he wants
queen to see he's trying to trade queens
nihal could could take on d4 he's still
better in the end game but queen b6
keeping the queens and andrew okay now
he drops his king back maybe evacuates
it to g2
i don't think he's actually much worse
if he manages to do that amazing
he's brought the king out he's tasted
fire but then now he's bringing it to
the king's side
c6 defending the pawns bringing the
knight back out andrew's doing fine all
things considered rook a5 might consider
nihil trying to stop him from
coming to the king side and the king is
going to get to g2 just like he said
dania and it looks reasonably safe
take on c3 maybe and then come to d2 at
the end you know biting his time knight
to d5 we have more trades
we have another draw and opposite color
bishops usually favors the attacker
queen g6 is an idea but it's just an
idea at the moment doesn't do anything
but now rook d7 you kind of called it
what does nihal do three seconds rook d7
and the tables have turned
bishop f7 okay very good move by nina
trying to trade queens take what the
rook is
is it gonna be made bishop d3 is made
it's made if he if he checks on d3 will
he see it he does
wow what a turn of the tables and
andrew defending and then finding the
opportunity to
jump onto the attack and now with a one
point lead amazing stuff mike
yeah that was great and a perfect
example of how when you get to the
middle game with opposite colored
bishops it's like having an extra piece
in the attack
and because of the nature of black's
pawns the f7 pawn was easily attackable
but white had pawns on f2 and e3 which
made the black's dark-squared bishop not
terribly useful in the attack on the
white king that's not one of those
features you have
even time to consider basically when
you're in a time scramble but
that's that's playing with fire that's
what happens you get down to these um
positions with 10 seconds left you don't
really have time to figure out who's
going to be favored in those types of
positions
exactly and uh you bring up a good point
here when you're
on the defensive and you have to deal
with concrete threats that can be one of
the hardest things to do in time
pressure and
i guess our query our question about
whether openings would be repeated well
it seems to be answered here we have
another one of these queens we get
andrew will definitely have to change
what he did in the opening right now
they're still repeating
all of the same moves mike i'm a little
bit surprised
yeah and it's way too early to call this
but if you're looking for a historical
since you're a history major donya
a historical time where a 16 beat a one
well it's only happened
once in the history of the ncaa
basketball tournament and it just so
happened to be a
school that's more known for its chess
championships that's
university of maryland baltimore county
as a 16 seed
beat virginia and this is a true story
in the locker room the basketball
players were asked
about this historic moment and they said
well we're just trying to keep up with
our school's chess team
because university maryland baltimore
county yep they won a couple of national
collegiate titles
and so chess has sort of paved the way
in a weird way for 16 seats to beat
number one seeds
incredible story wow and
it all comes together yeah um
there's actually another way that three
of the four people on this call are
related
dania and i are both broadcasting from
charlotte and andrew tang got his final
grandmaster norm
in charlotte so forget what copernicus
said the center of the universe is
charlotte it absolutely is i can totally
confirm that
and uh wow that's i can't get my head
but that is a really really cool stat i
of course the
upset the sports upset that is closest
to my heart is when the golden state
warriors i of course am from the bay
area
um and of course best wishes to everyone
right now in the bay area stuff
you know suffering through very very
tough conditions with the fires but
i i do remember when the warriors beat
the mavs in the first round of the
playoffs
um i think it was 2007 and the warriors
were the eighth seed
mavs were the top seed and i think that
was one of the only times in nba history
i'm just trying to one up you mike with
my sets but i don't think i ever well
that was really cool
wow what else is really cool is the
pressure that nihal is putting a black's
position yeah
i'll just close this down you by saying
steph curry is from charlotte but let's
get back to chess
that is he is from charlotte that's true
he went to davidson
um in any case so 95
and again white putting pressure on
black's position this knight potentially
coming to d7 it's a different kind of
pressure this time
andrew is not struggling with the
weakness of the a-pawn
nor is he trying to prevent white from
castling but
i mean maybe i'm not understanding
something but i just to me these
positions are so hard to play
especially in blitz i know this line is
popular but
it's like i get so cramped
yeah and the chances of the a4 pawn
being weak are several orders of
magnitude higher than the c6 pawn being
weak and
the pawn on a4 is only there to stop the
white pawn from bm2 from moving
whereas the pawn on c6 serves all kinds
of functions
limiting play the potential to become a
past pawn if c7 becomes weak
so if we just isolate those two pawns we
have to say
whites you don't often compare a c pawn
to an a pawn but white c
pawn has so much more utility than
black's a plan
that's exactly right and we see andrew
hunting for this knight on e5
nihol could consider something like
knight to d7 here
which has its own complicated sort of
ramifications he has taken on a6 first
so he's lessened some of the tension
now andrew's probably briefly
considering taking on e5 as an
intermediate move
i'm not liking that move necessarily
maybe bishop b7 then we have to consider
this line
with some potential stacks on h2 so
there is something to consider here
um and if you take on a6 maybe nihol
just wants to push out black's knight
and this rook on a6 is undefended that
could breed some tactics something like
queen d3
so again white is definitely better here
and andrew does go for bishop takes e5
um very interesting decision here and
now the ball is in the all score does he
go for this line but should be seven
and bishop takes a8 with a lot of
complexity here maybe andrew just wants
to draw his bishop back and go on the
counter attack
a little bit skeptical about that mike
but maybe he sees something there
i was trying to make that line work for
black as well but once white's g2 pawn
gets to g3
um i don't see how you break through
because white's queen is very close to
the king's side as well
unless there's a double sacrifice on g3
but then really you're just going for a
draw
right and i could actually not take the
bishop and go the queen e2
yes exactly right so i'm a little bit
puzzled as to
what andrew has in mind um one thing he
might be considering is to take on
e3 and just say okay i'm going to give
up the exchange but i'm going to have
this beautiful knight on on e4
and whatever it is nihal didn't like the
look of it he goes for bishop takes c5
alternatively he could have queen g4
okay so now he could have just said here
i have the initiative
i'm safe threatening checkmate either
forcing black snipe back or forcing
black to make a big weakness on the king
side of the g6
yeah i would have liked to have seen the
imbalance of the exchange sacrifice in
fact
andrew tang once played magnus carlson
over the board at the world rapid
championship
and magnus sacrificed in exchange
against andrew in a beautiful game
um so maybe i'm drawing a little bit of
a force parallel there but
i'm hoping to see a little bit of
imbalance today and we'll see if that
comes about in a future game
yeah and we do have is is it
an imbalance to say bishop against
knight is that
considered an imbalance i don't even
know yeah i think it's called the minor
exchange by kasparov right bishop for
night
the minor exchange yeah i think that is
a very memorable
aspire well you wouldn't yeah happen to
be playing anymore but
in any case uh we have andrew dropping
his knight back
to ea and the knight actually covers uh
two pawns at once now we had
a romanian grand master mihai shuba i
think had this famous quote the bad
bishops defend good pawns
here we kind of have a case of a bad
knight defending good pawns well
i don't even think these pawns are good
either so forget i said okay
i just forget it strike it off the
record but i think white is better white
is the one calling the shots here the
problem with these positions is they're
very locked up
what exactly is nihal's plan does he go
e4 and open up the center
does he sort of try to make marginal
improvements moves like h3
play a russian school of chess you know
slowly
what do you think um i was going to try
to play e4
i wanted to play f4 f5 but f4 fails to
f6 and you don't want to do that
right the bishop is trapped so yeah
maybe you know you have no files for
your rooks and rooks hate pawns as we
say in chess kid land
so putting a rook behind the e pawn and
advancing it to open up the position a
little bit for your bishop
would be sort of you know baseline chess
what you're supposed to do
right neal taking this lower push he
actually trades on d6
whoa that surprises me a little bit that
bishop was the main instrument of
pressuring that one
i feel like andrew is breathing a bit of
a sigh of relief after this now maybe
white is still better
white can still try to prepare e4 at his
convenience but
now he's got to be careful about this c6
pawn because he could easily turn from a
strength into a weakness
andrew could consider just going f5 and
stopping e4 altogether now that
the e5 square is yes it is weak but in
name only white has nothing to occupy it
with
yeah and you just made the first point
about the wedge pawn potentially
becoming a weakness which if i ever made
a chess kid video we'd have to talk
about
the closer you get to an end game the
space advantage means less and less
and the fact that the c6 pawn it's not
isolated by the strictest definition of
the chess word isolated
but for all intents and purposes it
can't be guarded by a pawn
and it just becomes weaker and weaker if
we swap the queens black's king will
just march to d6
and you'll be stuck using a rook to
guard the pawn forever it'll probably be
lost in a matter of
you know five or ten more moves it'll
take some time but it'll be lost
yeah and that is would be one of those
end games they show to russian school
children you know
position like when people refer to the
russian school of chess i think
playing these kinds of positions very
well is one of the hallmarks of it
um even though there is no like building
that is and that's one of the
misconceptions
that people have when they think of that
word the russian sculpture they think of
like a
stately building in moscow like there's
no building there's no literal
institution but it's more i would say
like a style of coaching and a style of
play
now here okay so he's redirecting his
queen to a6 but
now andrew has to be very careful that
we might be stranded and this might be a
good chance to make stuff happen
weakening black skinny side is knee hull
maybe e4 here maybe quickly go rookie
one and e4
so he's got a decision to make i think
if he doesn't go e4 now
he won't have another good chance
rook b5 okay now he's defending the pawn
maybe he's swinging the rook to b3
what is going on here but andrew dipping
low on the clock mike
yeah again the fewer pieces on the board
the more c6 becomes the
the most important part of the position
and in its weakness
but something else that has to be said
for the spawn on a4
blackstroke is kind of tied to it again
i feel like nihal they're playing this
cat and mouse game he keeps trying to
decide should i play e4 and andrew plays
e5 wow
i don't know about that he's opening up
the position so if you take on e5 maybe
he'll take back with the pawn he is
using the spawn on f6 to his advantage
now nihol with the decision does he keep
things closed with something like rook
d2
andrew might drive that wedge into e4 i
don't think that bothers knee hall
i just think this might be a draw uh if
he allows it to happen
but i'm not sure it's a good idea to
take an e5 you've played a ton of online
blitz matches if you're white here would
you ever take into account the clock
situation in your actual move decision
making at this point
not with andrew i've done this so many
times i think there's no way even with
increment there's no way he's going to
make it
andrew even with no increment with 10
seconds it can play a very accurate rook
end game so
i would play something measured he does
take though okay so maybe he wants to go
after this pawn on d5
um but this took me a lot of time in his
own right now they're about equal on the
clock queen to e6 depending upon
pressuring c6
what to do for white maybe queen to g3
okay needle dropping his rook back
i think it's still about balanced um i
don't think either side has a measurable
advantage i do like what andrew has done
here
now he seems to be the one with the
initiative maybe get this rook back to
a8
stopping a potential check on v8 okay he
locks the queen of
g5 does knee help play f4 that seems
very risky
again let's buckle in and watch things
happen here
strange position where the black rooks
are not working together yet they both
seem to be doing more than the white
counterparts
exactly they're both on the fake rank
but somehow as he as you say well now
neil trying to remedy that situation
pressure
maybe queen to h1 and he does rook to h
work takes h5 i know it's not
zero esque right there indeed it did but
e4 locks the queen into g2
now he's got that block getting for
three seconds for knee-hill he's
definitely worse now he wins another
punt things are spinning out of control
andrew wentworth have six he's
threatening rook takes f2 yeah
alekhine's gun coming there it is
oh look at this this has turned around
completely and deep white has lost that
c6 upon android pressing on the kingside
h4
look at that defense shutting white down
completely this is mastery by andrew and
he's got a lot more time as well
only a miracle oh he had rook take c6
there actually maybe
okay h4 and this just seems to be okay
nihal trying trying to complicate things
that's actually a really good move
exploiting the sun definitely broken who
definitely missed that
and if h takes what was that
queen is overworked that's the point of
the tactic it is look at andrew's clock
three seconds now they've equalized
amazing stuff that me hull
oh and the blood is the rook and after
an incredible but still it was worse of
course it was very tough to save that
and andrew prevails again
mike two and a half to a half exactly
finale
in the live ratings uh andrew's even
catching up a little bit not that
matters for the match you just gotta
score
one more point than your opponent indeed
that is
incredible and so exciting are these
finales
you think five minutes that's so much
time but they're so close in strength
that
each game seems to come down to final
seconds
as they are off with a london system a
vintage
weapon for andrew which he has played
for years and years and years now
and uh kind of frustrating for neil on
two accounts number one
he was not able to put away another game
where that c6 pawn we both agreed
was a useful pawn and number two he went
from being up
a minute to what was it about 20 seconds
to being
down uh 15 seconds or three seconds
so so far we are seeing that uh the
speed of andrew even if nihal is pretty
fast
you know somebody's got a tesla
ludicrous mode and that would be andrew
indeed and uh he is very comfortable in
these structures and what you said i
it's interesting that you can be better
but sometimes the mantle of making a
decision
is always upon you we saw nihol there
you have
to always does he play e4 here does he
break through there
that burns a lot of clock inevitably so
in those cases sometimes actually being
worse
can be less of a burden than being
better in name only but having to decide
you know sort of when you break through
i want to welcome the many thousands of
viewers who have tuned in this is the
opening round
of the 2020 chess.com junior speed chess
championship sponsored by chess kid got
to throw that in you can see in the
background behind me that's why you see
it
and we've got the number one seed nihal
sarin playing the knockout qualifier
andrew tang andrew had to win a bunch of
matches this week just to get here
and so far he's got a two-game lead
against the number one seed
he does now i wouldn't say nihal is
terribly concerned he's very measured
he's not very prone to tilt um as far as
i know
and uh he's got a decent position here
not much to say and he's go he goes e5
so he's exploiting this undefended
bishop on d3 if andrew takes the hall
will take back
and that d3 bishop will hang so
where does ander but the b might have
missed this move now he can play bishop
g3
it's not a big problem but knee hall
tactically sharp here
i'm actually not sure what nihal will do
after bishop g3 because if you take then
black is left with a slightly weak bond
on d6
he does it i just wanted to mention
irrespective of this game donya
uh if you have any uh kopecks or rubles
in your pocket that you'd like to bet
the smart money is actually still on
nihal sauron
according to the statistical oddsmakers
you can see right there he's still got
about a 60 chance of winning not quite
as good as joe biden but
uh you know the smart money is still on
nihal star and at the moment so
we all know though that it's only as
good as form and so far
andrew even though he's not gotten some
great positions he's been able to
convert a little bit better so
i don't know would you put money on a
player who's down two games and has not
been better in any game yet or not
i i don't think so in fact just give me
a second i'm getting a full hey uh
sports bettors yeah you're fired all
right that was that was a terrible
performance all right bye
uh i don't know because again i'm i
think
in terms of raiding of course knee hall
is a better player
classical chess andrew is just so good
at blitz it's
just unbelievable the guy is i mean i
think you cannot use the speed a rating
as
any kind of measuring stick now i do
think this is going to be a close match
i still think this is going to come down
to the bullet
um as in i don't think it's going to be
lopsided but
i don't think andrew is or i don't think
nihal is the favorite
yeah still pretty early to tell and i
don't have um i mean i used to be the
stat guy for chess.com but
uh you know we've we've uh i've gotten a
little bit busy with chess kid and matt
jensen has done a great job with the
stats but
the biggest comeback ever back when we
just used to do
death matches i believe was five games
i think yaakov norowitz came back
and irena crush was maybe down five
games as well
against um one of the kazinsva sisters
but
when you get past five i doubt we've had
any one-on-one match where somebody's
come back
unless there's just a match i'm not
remembering uh we're a long way away
from that but uh you kind of wanna
you wanna put your stop gap there and
say let's not get past four or five
yeah and it appears that nehal is better
here i think
andrew has let something slip look at
his king side all these weak squares on
the king side he's trying to
to sort of patch things together but
this bishop more like a band-aid than a
permanent fix
uh nihal can try to trade it off with
bishop d6 and then later swing his
knight to f4
there's also a potential exchange
sacrifice i'm not sure it's
quite time for that yet but there's
stuff to consider here for sure
you know again these dark squares are so
so weak for white
so i think andrew was lulled to sleep a
little bit here by the symmetrical
structure
but definitely a chance here for knee
hall if he can play this accurately
yeah i'm looking at the player's
expressions even though nihal is well
they both look pretty calm
when andrew plays chess what gets me is
that he almost looks
bored even though he's playing so fast
does that ever affect your uh do you
ever look at your player's camera in
public one-on-one matches because you've
played a lot of them this summer
i do occasionally just to sort of gauge
and i try not to fall in love with that
because sometimes it's either
underwhelming in terms of you know if i
play andrew and i'm okay
so tilted i want to say flagged him and
andrew's just
has the same expression as if he's up
10-0
um but contrary on the contrary if your
opponent
is showing visible signs of frustration
that can give you that little push
and that reinforcement you need so i i
sometimes like to gauge uh
my opponent's expression but i wouldn't
put too much stock in it as you say
andrew is
i mean the guy is just unbelievably
level-headed and uh it's
you know at this point it's become
legendary and for very good reason
and perhaps i should not have dipped my
toes in any political waters but we have
a good joke in the
in the twitch chat uh somebody's saying
that the tang gang
is well represented so not the yang gang
but uh
does that mean that every chess fan gets
a uh a monthly stipend from the
government that's what the tang gang
should be behind right
well but with andrew's speed maybe he
deserves
he's yeah el nino here he might need
some speed to convert this advantage
because he's now taking over a minute
i still like the move bishop d6 um
just trying to trade the bishops and get
access to those dark squares
i know it looks a little bit plain
vanilla but this can unravel very very
quickly for white
uh with queen g3 and knight f4 yeah it's
not often you see such a horrible bishop
for black on b7 and yet black
is probably the one dictating the action
so if black could just fix that one
problem
of his bishop on b7 then every advantage
would be his i think indeed
and uh as andrew ponder says move we
actually have some really really cool
calculations uh to share with you guys
uh we have the smarter chess match
prediction these statistical predictions
so as
we can see the prediction is for new
hope to win the five minute portion i
don't know how realistic that is
and he's listed as the favorite here
statistically for
all sections including the bullet with a
75
win probability uh with a pretty
lopsided prediction mike
hot take on that i think 75 might be
about right i mean i did demure at the
beginning of the broadcast when you
asked for a legitimate prediction but
smarter chess you know that's like the
538 of the chess world i believe these
stats
however again i will go back to what
i've said usually one versus 16
is you know as a chess fan you're just
basically watching nakamura or magnus
just you know play cat and mouse with
somebody but this is a legitimate match
as we've seen in the opening 30 minutes
where the 16 i mean one in four is a
real chance you would not
you bet your life on a one and four coin
flip and by the way what coin are you
using
but um that's what makes you go
intrigued by the junior speed chess
championship
yeah literally every match could go
either way that that is
just incredible but this game seems to
be
spiraling somewhat out of control for
andrew as we've discussed these weak
squares on the king side and part of the
problem could be that if he takes the
pawn
take the bishop back which he has to
queen c5 check follows then this queen
infiltrates to f2
followed by knight f4 this is nasty
nasty stuff for andrew that's why he's
thinking
maybe he's trying to find some sudden
research he has to take the bishop if
you take to the rook
the same thing might follow i'm not even
sure black needs the rook
uh to mount a decisive invasion on the
kings side
so he has taken with the rook that seems
to be the lesser evil
but again we see he's sort of dragging
his feet here queen c5 follows i don't
see a defense after queen f2 honestly
yeah you know why i mean the only event
of trading rooks if you play king f1
knight g3 is not made now that's not a
ringing endorsement for playing king f1
but it was an extra possibility but i
think you're spot on
uh it's possible there's multiple ideas
but don't play queen eve
i was about to say don't play queen e3
you're thinking it's the same thing yeah
absolutely now one thing he might be
concerned about if queen f2 knight f1
knight of four andrew does have queen c2
he's sort of holding on it's not mate
even in this position queen before it's
obviously much much better for black
maybe niel is trying to find the most
accurate way to put andrew away
we have seen time and time again
incredible resilience on display from
andrew so
you certainly don't want to be sloppy in
the conversion stage and he starts with
knight f4 so he tries to keep things
flexible
bishop f1 is likely now maybe he's just
gonna go after this pawn on e5 playing
something like queen d4
uh double attacking the knight of the
fun but in that case andrew does have
queen c3 so
it's not completely over and 27 seconds
is a little bit concerning
uh for nioh so he's gonna have to be
crisp here it should be noted that if
you play
i don't know something weird like king
g3 to cover f2 then the simple queen d4
seems to pick off a piece because of the
multiple pieces on the d file
great point and they are both basically
undefended
i'm not sure what's stopping andrew from
going bishop f1 um
maybe there's some sort of resource that
i miss maybe quinn f2 i mean
it's a slightly different version and he
does it now queen c3 or queen c2 seems
forced to defend the knight then the
hulk could involve that d-pawn send it
down the board open up that bishop
um so okay so he goes g5 he basically
accumulates the pressure the problem for
andrews is queen's tied to this knight
so it doesn't seem feasible for andrew
to generate counter play against black's
king although that is something to think
about
eventually just dropping that knight on
d2 going queen d6
and throwing your chips into the center
of the table
yeah i'm trying to work out a way for a
repetition after queen d6
um i think thinking about that also i
think you should just do it i mean i
think that's the last resort
and he's thinking i i think he's to do
it he's going queen c3 so he's going for
c7 similar idea
but i i thought that was actually a
chance okay definitely c7 seems like a
no-brainer to me
okay queen c1 so he's still holding back
maybe he's
hunting for the right opportunity which
is a bit of a gamble but three seconds
for andrew and
again the time scribble so he's going
into passive defense mode
he is challenging the hell to find a way
forward but now d392 i do not like that
approach from andrew i think this gives
black
a much easier time of it bishop takes
age three
and then knight e4 okay he's holding it
together queen c2 you can't take the
queen
look at that move from andrew amazing
and he's holding it together he's losing
time
wow just like you said donya passive
defense you have to keep solving
problem after problem if you just chuck
your chips in as you say you know what
you're trying to do you're trying to
just
check or promote a pawn or something
it's much more clear what you're trying
to do
that final move bishop f5 also mike was
actually incredibly strong from nihal
because he was
threatening to capture the knight on e4
and the queen would lose its defender so
i actually think even objectively it was
very very bad
uh for andrew and he's definitely going
to have to adjust that uh in these time
scrambles
and uh nihal well he's gaining a point
back and it's only a one point game
we have a somewhat unconventional
already here where niho has doubled back
and decided to fee and keto his bishop
so not too theoretical double fianchetto
now
on the board andrew putting putting out
a slav structures very solid position
black knee hull not going for the
opening advantage mic but
just a slow roll kind of game yeah
really weird to play
g3 and e3 that's one of those general
rules you tell kids you know
if you've already played g3 don't play
e3 or vice versa because your bishop can
only pick one diagonal so
what do you make of this decision if if
white had played d3 it would just be
some sort of like you know reverse
dragon setup but
uh why is white able to get away with
this weird structure
well the thing is uh it's it's one of
those things classic modern chess
right the concrete i guess specifics of
the position
supersede the general principle usually
the reason you're told not to play this
is because these
squares that i'm highlighting are left
very weak but because of the way white
set
this up his queen is guarding d3 he can
take on e5
i would say i'm not a huge fan of this
setup but
you know you could try to kind of work
around the edges here with knight a4
knight c5 so it has i guess it's
charm and it could be one of those
provocative openings where
you frustrate your opponent right you
think and i should get an advantage
against this and you fail to do so and
then equality can feel like
a defeat well while we've got a little
bit of a lull and and don
i'll give you i'll i'll burn 20 seconds
for you a little bit of extra analysis
in your head
on my chest kids shows i love to do a
little bit of trivia so i
i was trying to think of a trivia
question that related to the first 45
minutes of chess that we've seen here
and i think i've come up with one
although the problem is it's a little
bit
subjective and not objective but here we
go i'm going to try it anyway
we've been talking a lot this afternoon
about pawn wedges so my question
to all of the fans is which game which
was voted best game of the 90s
by informator i believe it was best game
involved maybe one of the best pawn
wedges of all time
wow so don is going to think about it
maybe our fans are going to think about
it too
i don't actually know if it was voted
best game or maybe it was like number
two game
but it clearly is the best pawn wedge
game of the 90s so
maybe i'll restructure my question that
way what's the best pawn wedge game of
the 90s
so i even got kudos from from smarter
chess on my questions so
anyway so we can be looking at our
chessboard here why everybody uh
in the chat tries to tell me what the
answer is
well thanks for distracting me for the
rest of the commentary mike let me
distract you and ask you a trivia
question that is a
much lower caliber but nihal sarin was
asked if he has a
chess nickname um what does he look like
to you mike what would you give nihal
as a nickname based on how much of a
beast he is on the board
uh well i i happen to know what his
friends call him so are you wanting me
to reveal that information i do want you
to realize
as we think about the pawn wedge game
his friends call him the devil
uh well yeah he's pretty soft-spoken
when i've interviewed him in the past
i'm a little bit surprised by that we
didn't get a chance to ask andrew the
same question
because well he just qualified a couple
of days ago and i'm sure he was busy
preparing for the match so if anybody in
the chat has a better name
or a non you know friend name for nihal
a more professional nickname
he may be open to uh to different
nickname ideas if anybody's got it
in the chat i'm actually looking to see
if anybody has the answer to my question
some people are saying kasparov topolov
now that was in the 90s he snuck in
there in 99 but
i don't remember a pawn wedge
so is it a single pawn that you're from
or like maybe upon chain
it's absolutely a single pawn and a
single pawn that's what i thought yeah
and you and i know when we talk about
pawn wedges we're usually talking about
a center pawn because that literally
divides the board
into two hemispheres and this pawn did
exactly that
uh i'm looking to see if anybody's got
it i don't think anybody has i'm trying
to check both
chats i'm thinking too but i'm
huh you know the game oh wait
okay well one of our staff members
smarter chess got it right
i don't know if he was the first one i
actually don't know that game
yeah smarter chess got okay so smarter
chess you win a premium subscription
that you already get forever anyway
um it's yvonne chuck youssef 91
where yusupov gets the pawn on e3 and
continually threatens mate on f2 like
for the entire game
and sacrifices his entire queen side to
force me
i'm going to have to look at that game
yeah okay i'll take over chat while you
do a 30 second
find on that game was it one no it was
in brussels 91.
it was actually a rapid game but yvonne
chuck yusuf off fantastic game it's
i'll try to take over the commentary
while you google that um
something in chestnut land that we call
the corkscrew
because the bishop on g2 is the key
to popping the white king so when you
trade bishops it's like
popping the corkscrew on a wine bottle
and the general rule is
if somebody corkscrews you don't take
because you're inviting the black queen
into your territory you want black to
take you so that when your king takes
back
you deprive the enemy queen access in
this case to h3
and the other side would be h6 but
white's got the weak pawns in this
position
except for a7 which black seems to have
just sacrificed
let's see if we can figure out what is
going to happen if the pawn on a7 gets
captured
um the idea
is what yeah oh b5 oh what a
man it's almost as if he's known as the
devil
yeah well i mean what an idea what a
devilish idea i got tricked by it
so e4 by oh no no that's that's andrew
the andrew spring in the trap
but he holds the devil for not falling
into it um
huh so e4 he's basically trying to blunt
the influence of the rooks
can you take now them
okay but then we take and go like 95
maybe this looks yeah somehow your
knight clears off the seventh rank with
tempo as you've shown and then b5
resumes it's
it's ugly head mike i'm so sorry to
rejoin the commentary i know you had a
great time without me
my apologies i actually needed you to
see that game
because that's one of those things
that's going to eat at you for the rest
of the broadcast you you must have seen
that game now that you've looked at it i
think
it rings about a distant bell i think
probably my coach showed it to me years
ago
but i will say and i will confess it you
know full disclosure
i'm not as well versed in some of sort
of the classics as
some of my fellow gm's i think i know a
fair amount but but there's a lot of
games that i that i just haven't seen
and so i you know yeah you you've got
350 rating points on me but i've got a
decade or more of
just browsing chess books so and you've
got a lot of trivia under your belt as
well just going to brag on your behalf
also dania i was alive when informatory
was a real thing
i mean i i i actually have some
informator and um
i actually have this affinity for old
school stuff like that
so i like flip phones and old books and
information so i do have that side of me
uh which which respects that kind of
stuff a lot you know i guess a nostalgia
for it
so yeah in any case i think they might
still be making them i'm not sure
yeah i think that maybe they're
digitized so check out informator if you
have
that particular passion and andrew is
checking out that d3 pawn so has this
opening strategy backfired for nihal
his position is solid i don't see a way
directly to break through
for andrew maybe activate this rook via
e6
but you also have to be careful maybe
just create some loft on the background
with h6
because that could also come back to
impact black
okay d e by by andrews he's opening up
the file i would say de
should be the proper recapture for niho
i mean fe allows knight g4 that seems
pretty unthinkable
is something bothering him though
yeah i mean you want to activate your
rook you want fewer pawn islands but the
number one reason is just like you said
the g4 square is a little bit too weak
to allow knight to g4
that's right and there is an interesting
tactic where b5 knight c5 then you take
on g2 and by knight takes f3
swinging that queen over to okay so he
has taken but now he has activated the
rook via e6 of course a7 is still
untouchable
white's queen is tied down to this f3
pawn and andrew swinging his rook around
probably to h6 but maybe also to f6
yeah i think it's a position where he's
going to keep toggling his rook to force
white's pawns to advance
and then eventually the want the pawns
are going to be vulnerable so like rook
h6
h4 rook g6 and then it's getting kind of
hard to push pawns because if you play
g4 knight takes g4
almost certainly looks winning something
like that yeah exactly i'm just showing
it on the board
white's whole position collapses black
is more than enough attackers
and again we see 30 seconds to 43
seconds it is going to be another
scramble and this is one of the worst
kinds of positions to play
when you don't have much time remaining
on your clock i don't see off the top of
my head mic a way to
to protect everything uh now knight
takes f3 here is actually possible
and queen takes c5 that would be okay he
goes for cup six and knife d7 trying to
root that knight out
so what is what if rook takes f3 though
what if rook takes f3
i guess he wants queenie two and now the
rook is kind of
stranded i don't really believe in that
but will andrew find a refutation in
time
maybe rook takes f3 knight g4 something
crazy
whoa this is a very interesting idea by
the whole
andrew could also go rook h6 here just
kind of taking a step back
he's definitely trying to calculate rook
takes f3 but he's down to 10 seconds
this is going to be another time
scramble squandering the time advantage
to try to find the knockout blow but if
you don't find it you've just burned up
80 percent of your time on this one he's
got two seconds he's gotta make a move
rook age six so he bails out knee-hill
probably breathing a side relief now
oh and okay you could not have taken on
h2 there the king was escaping now it
fizzles out a little bit queen takes a7
is now possible
and the tables have turned andrew into a
little bit too much clock mike
if you trade queens too the white rooks
make a lot more sense in the black rooks
because the attack just fizzled to
nothing
exactly and now one pawn to the good and
one second friend if he is trying to
unfortunately trade a queen that's a
great move that would have been a great
move but he goes after the pawns andrew
trying to
rip open the king position five seconds
for nihal he is definitely not out of
the woods
trying to trade queensland or refusing
of course a four maybe just start
pushing the pawn wreckage one stopping
h4
all right what's going on here queen
e500 trying this way and that way to get
to white's position
another time scramble y'all activating
his rook via c5 what a maneuver
oh he blunders his queen oh that works
oh
but okay it was already lost i was going
to suggest queen d4 to trade queens but
if you know your opponent's gonna
blunder the queen then clearly he knows
more than i do
no that was that would have been a great
move and a bit of a heartbreaker
there mike for andrew who seemed to have
that incredibly strong attack going and
just not quite enough time to calculate
the ramifications
of rook takes f3 so a very savvy choice
by new hope to go 97
that was the turning point and the score
ladies and gentlemen is tight
second win in a row for knee hall and
what we've seen so far is having the
better position is not always worked out
to victories uh
these couple positions were white where
neal's got the strong wedge pawn
neither one is led to victory andrew was
better most that game
this reminds me of a very frustrating
experience when i was a kid playing
mario kart
where the number two player always got
the better weapons and overtook the
number one player on the final lap
so anyway smarter chess i'm not sure
what the predictions were for a mario
kart reference in the first hour oh but
it's 101
where i'm sitting so i did not get the
mario kart reference in in the first
hour i can't help you that because i've
never played mario kart
i was my my go-to game was age of
empires that is basically the only game
i played and super smash brothers on an
old nintendo 98
with my brother those were the only two
games i played as a kid
well we're actually borrowing from video
games on my last chess kids show with
national master alice lee we did a speed
run
just like they try to do on video games
where you try to beat the video game as
quickly as possible
alice and i did a speed run to see who
could beat all the bots the fastest
but actually our speed run was mostly
who could beat the most spots in 10
minutes
there's a problem with a speed run on
the chess kid bots you want to hear what
the problem is
i do well during quarantine as you
probably know
vishyanan was stuck in germany because
of the flight situation
and was uh trying to play his son on
chess kid
whose son was still in india and uh
that she talks to me on whatsapp and
he's like mike i've got this question um
how strong is bot level 10 on chess kid
and i said well vishy you know i can't
beat level 10 i assume it's an im or gm
string
and vichy says to me mike i can't beat
level 10.
[Laughter]
i said okay maybe you made that bot too
hard now in fairness to vichy
i don't think he was taking it that
seriously he did say if he focused
really hard
he thinks he would have a good chance
but um but there you go bot level 10 i
think it's called uh
it's called megahertz i have to remember
what our bots are called
interesting well vishy can't beat it
then that's that's a pretty good
indicator
even bishop not taking something
seriously is still fishy
and what have i done admitting that i
never played mario kart i normally like
daniel's commentary but this is
unbearable oh man
i have reached a point of no return mike
i should have never said that you know i
can hang my queen on analysis and
they'll laugh and call the bow test
gambit we'll have a good time
but you'll never be forgiven if there's
a piece of
culture that they've experienced that
you haven't so
i was too busy playing a board game my
apologies yeah like
don't tell anybody but i've never seen
lord of the rings and if people find out
about that
then i'll never hear it we won't even be
able to go back to chess for the next
three hours
are we still on air oh goodness i think
we might still be on air mike
yes as ben we are both going to be fired
after this broadcast
is there a level of this microphone
lower than mute that's a ben feingold
joke
that's funny yeah i think that also i
i had that element of russian upbringing
so
some of the sort of stuff i did it was
somewhat unconventional
um and some of the stuff i watched as a
kid i did love scooby-doo though that
was my
so my school ended at three and i
remember
um just running home and watching the
reveal of the
monster at scooby-doo that was my moment
of my day
i i can't add anything that conversation
except that um you'll always be an
eight-year-old boy to me don't you
oh well that's very sweet i don't think
i can continue this broadcast i'm
getting emotional
all right so knight b6 now let's take a
look at
the game we have a middle game on the
board another london
where andrew has well a knight on b6
right in the sort of midst in the
heartland of black's position this
knight on g5 though
it's in a little bit of trouble although
i guess it has the e4 square
in case of h6 now notice if black goes
h6 he can take on e6 and this knight on
g6 is going to be undefended so it's
actually kind of annoying
andrew preparing to expand on the queens
i was super he is definitely better here
i think he has
gotten sort of his type of position what
niho could consider is something like e5
at the right moment maybe you break
through in the center you try to mix
things up because again black is very
very crimped
but mike we've seen nihal very very sort
of
measured and good in these positions
even when it seems like his position is
pretty cramped
yeah i mean but the goal remember donya
is to get the slightly worse position
i'm not sure that uh nihal's got the
memo on that
yeah exactly the knight on b6 is one of
those funny pieces that's controlling a
lot of squares and as being an octopus
but might never get out
right exactly um so it might you might
as well try to support it there now
maybe one way that
uh andrew's trying to hedge his bets
when he does play c4 if neil takes
the knight does have this potential
evacuation route through a4 which
i agree is not ideal but as they say in
russian this night is an eternal night
which kind of goes into what you're
saying mike it can't be chased
it can't be won by a pawn but it's kind
of
pretty much there forever
so nicole taking his time here this is
an important moment he could try to play
knight t5 and trade off the knights
that's one one option
um but andrew could follow up with c4
and that knight could be replaced by
upon ledge wait is this this would be
known as upon wedge right
or no well no because it's behind the
black pawn so it's a little bit obscure
you know ah so it's behind the bottom of
the five inches
i think it doesn't count as a wedge
because it's not blocking a black pawn
which would really inhibit the space
it's
it's on the other side so it's just it's
strange you know
that it's like casting owen wilson in
the movie behind enemy lines it's just a
strange
choice aha they're totally yes i've seen
that
movie many times my favorite one
willston
see when you say wilson the only
association i make is
uh wilson in castaway that might have
been a few movies to make me cry
i don't i'm not usually i'm kind of get
emotional while watching a movie type
kind of guy but
that was that got to me for sure well
what about isolation
when you play these online matches do
you like to be in a house with nobody
else so there's no chance of
like i i'll be honest with you when i do
broadcast i don't even want anybody
around me because just
i want this feeling of like um
you know like this being my my inner
quiet place
so i agree completely um and it's
it's the case for me when i do broadcast
or when i play tournaments
um sort of i like to be fully fully
engaged but the first few times i played
um
i played magnus uh in these long matches
i was in my
dorm room's computer cluster with sort
of my friends just talking
um and that can actually add an element
of sort of
it can lighten the feeling of playing a
high stakes or high stress match
but i agree like when you're
broadcasting you just need to be fully
fully engaged
let me ask you when you're in your dorm
room and you're playing the best player
in the world
do your friends have any idea what's
going on so
how do you describe that to them so the
first time i got paired with magnus
um in in one of the titled arenas i i
so i was you know i was just sort of
playing casually and i was prepared to
magnussen so i tell my my friends
okay guys you need to kind of quiet down
here playing magnus and of course they
knew who magnus is i mean they
they've heard of magnus they're not
chess players but they don't fully
understand the magnitude
get it magnus magnitude of playing
magnus
so i was trying to kind of not be
obnoxious but
i think it was very clear to them that i
had suddenly become 100 times more
intense
um and eventually they kind of
understood
um but yeah it was interesting the
knight on b6 does have a route back to
the game but now black is faced with the
question of whether or not to take
and the classic question of the day is
it a strong pawn or is it a weak pawn my
first inclination is that it's quite
weak
right but it could be used as a decoy
and white could break through in the
center with something like d5
and if this happens well that f7 pawn is
going to be things can collapse here for
black so the problem might be not so
much the pawn
as the pawn uses it so you could maybe
take and go rookie 7
lending more support to the c6 one but
obviously now the spawn could become a
strength
and the queen could swing around to a5
and a6 a6 is suddenly
uh very very weak as well so this is a a
definite pickle for black if andrew does
not if niho does nothing
then white could take on t5 and ruin
black's pawn structure h6
might be considered here uh by knee hall
but again
white could take on d5 simply drop his
knife back and guess what he's got a big
positional advantage here with this
terrible bishop facing the spawn
double pawns in the center so big time
decision by neil i think andrew is
so far playing an excellent positional
game
yeah and andrew has burned a lot of time
as well
despite the fact that we generally
regard him as being a little bit of a
faster player
that that lack of time will they cost
him in the previous game and it's the
reason that this match is tied
he might have been able to hold that
position
for it not for him being down 10 seconds
in game number five
that's exactly right and dipping below
30 seconds
now is knee hull so okay so h6 so he's
decided on this move chasing the night
away now again a decision trainer does
he in fact
take on d5 and as you said mike i think
he needs to make these decisions a
little bit faster go
with his gut his intuition is incredible
and i can just attest to that firsthand
uh but we see him burning through his
time advantage here so he's trying to
do i take this knife maybe if bishop d5
nihal could actually take the knight
in order to preserve the integrity of
his pawn structure more or less in the
center
but again andrew could go after that on
an a6 let's see what is what decision he
makes
he does go for bishop takes d5 and
d-hall actually takes back with his
bishop
so andrew could take and he has a stable
advantage here the pawn majority on the
queen side
but both below 30 seconds this is going
to be yet another time scramble every
single game mike
has come down to basically a time
scramble fascinating stuff
yeah and the double pawns while they may
look like a weakness they actually
deprive
white's pieces of a lot of entry squares
so they're not
fun to look at but they do a great job
of guarding a bunch of squares in the e
file
that white's pieces would like to use
great point and it could also be an
anchor point for blackstroke to reach e4
okay so andrew has pushed his pawn to b4
where it is now pressured by the rook
knee hall could bring his queen to b8 he
decides to bring his knight over to c6
as you say these double pawns they
they're restricting white somewhat and
again is this a strength or is it a
weakness that pawn on before now the
subject of discussion queen 27 it seems
like black is very solid here
it's not going to be easy to break
through and or definitely still with the
advantage going after this pawn
rook b5 looks good for black here he's
got to make a move here we go five
seconds
queen f593 would be a problem so he
chooses e6 instead
but that allows rookie one with tempo
interesting decision
and he does it he had knight 64 there
actually which would be an interesting
tactic
aha so queen pressuring the knight on c2
now knight takes a five point d5 he's
gonna make a move two seconds for any
hall here we go
attacking the knight he's moving it
around to b5
all right it's reflexes o'clock let's
see if andrew's older mouse
i think it it has on so many occasions
he's definitely still better pushing in
the end game
bishop on f8 so passive that pawn on a6
now very weak this is going to be so
hard to defend he's picking off the pawn
94
dropping the rook back to c4 and slow
rolling it now is andrew he does not
have to rush
rook c6 a huge threat knee-high going
after the ball the only thing he can do
generating some counter play
but will it be enough i don't think so
look at those passers look at those
snappers 86
the knight guards all the squares on the
8th amazing needs
and now it gives itself away for the
greater good this is going to be
unstoppable pawns
for andrew and nihal accepting the
inevitable resigning amazing performance
there by andrew keeping the pressure
his foot on the gas pedal all the way
basically from start to finish wired to
wire
victory as he jumps up on top by one
point mike
he managed the end game well he puts to
bed that two game mini winning streak
from nihal once again takes the lead
and i just want to check the match clock
here how much time is left in the five
minute section a little bit less than 20
minutes
yeah it looks like it so this will not
be the final game we'll have at least
two more games
in this section and uh you know we
sometimes play the hypothetical game in
these matches
hypothetically would andrew like to be
tied
at least tied after the five-minute
segment i have to think yes i think
that andrew is putting a little bit more
of his hopes and his stakes on the
faster time
he's playing just fine in the five
minute and despite the increment
he he wants you know he's looking for
the bullet section the increment does
not fully
as we have seen counteract the effect of
last time
and uh i think he might have that
marginal edge in time scrambles as
we see nihal taking his time on move
five
so yeah we see nihal taking his time
here with a kind of a lie that has
become fashionable recently mike
it's almost like a queen's indian
defense in reverse or something
yeah and uh i've seen this hikaru is a
big fan of this
system with white it can actually
contain some venom if black does not
handle the central tension properly that
extra tempo
as you say could come in very handy i
think andrew is doing a good job of this
now
one example of this would be if you just
kind of take everything in a castle and
you're very casual
well guess what white can take on c6
take on g7 and then
fork the king and the pawn so this
transformation could actually be a
little bit negative for black
so andrew with some important decisions
here in the early going
i got to ask you saw that so quickly is
that a canned trap that you'd seen
before did you just figure that out so
quickly i'm just
like there's no i'm not big on cam
straps okay
okay um just that's i i hate canned
traps as much as i
can tuna okay i don't like tuna so i
don't like traps
but i've seen ideas like this before and
usually um
a lot of people wonder about this you
know how do i see stuff quickly a lot of
it is pattern recognition i've seen
something similar right
a similar fork even though it's been
wearing different clothes
so well let me ask another question in
the early moments of the game as we try
to figure out where the players are
going to
sort out their pieces i think the first
trivia question went well so
let's try another one of the 16 players
in
the chess.com junior speed chess
championship which one
has played in an official event on chess
kid we used to have an
a chess kid national championship it was
called the chess kid online national
invitational championship
that's a mess so we called it conic but
anyway
which of the 16 players has played in
the official flight it was in the very
fledgling days of jessica there you see
all the players on the screen
so you've got to pick one of them and i
believe this was back in 2013. so i'm
going to follow
see who gets it right you'll get your
name announced on the air i don't know
if i have license to give away premium
memberships but i'll at least announce
her name on the air
and i'm looking at the chess.com tv chat
yes but i won't say it until later yeah
this one you can use your powers of
deduction have a pretty good idea
i actually don't know i i mean it's just
basically a wild guess
but that's really interesting and it's
only been one
huh i think only one and we have a
correct answer
from actually this is a person who often
comes to my chest kid live streams
that's
uh chitta yang tiringari
i'm sorry of course we already have a
famous membership so i apologize i
botched your name it's
jeffrey xiong played back in 2013.
seems like just a moment ago but he was
a kid he's still a kid
well you're still a kid compare if
you're talking to
you know if your mom or something but uh
jeff is literally a kid back then
that is true wow how time flies mike i
remember jeffrey as a feed a master
then an i am guess what he's over 2 700
now all grown up well
to me i guess it all depends on your
perspective
um and uh yeah i love those trivia
questions that's really interesting
it's just so cool to watch the
progression of these young players you
know as they start out and then
they become stronger and stronger now
you're just a touch older than these
players not too much but
would you say that the players were
watching now
are the first generation where
internet chess was practically required
to get better i don't
know if i'm phrasing this question the
way i want to i mean i know you must
have played a ton of internet chess
but in the last five to eight years
internet chess has gotten so much bigger
and you were already a gm five years ago
yeah i would say that i i i think i see
what you're saying
um i and i would say the answer is yes
now in my generation
it was sort of split 50 50 between
people who were big on
online chess when they were little
growing up i was one of those people i
played
you know tons and tons basically since
the time i was seven
but i know many quite a few grandmasters
right around my age who were just not
that big on
online chess as well and the generation
coming after which is who we're watching
now
virtually all of them have a very very
deep footprint on of online chess
yeah i asked all the players a couple of
pre-event questions and
i did not ask the question what was the
most formative chess book you read
you read growing up because i think i
might have gotten a lot of kids to say
they never really read a chess book
right that's very true and
sometimes i actually find it very hard
to answer those questions and i'm like
put on the spot and i just for it's like
what's your favorite movie and then you
forget every single movie i've ever
watched you know what i'm saying
but but you're right i mean it's it's
not that kids don't read chess books but
there's just so many resources now that
there's various paths to take
uh for improvement and um yeah it'll
definitely be interesting to explore
uh their their training routines and how
they've reached the top
but just taking a look at the game we
see andrew's clock very very concerning
50 seconds after 14 moves i mean this is
a massively lopsided time situation now
i don't think black is worse here andrew
trying to put pressure on that
on d4 the only issue is that bishop on
e4 really has no way
no way back right nihil could even
consider something like knight h2
and he will be threatening to trap the
bishop and so does black need to play g6
in an emergency g5 sorry to get the
[ __ ] i think he might
but that creates its own weaknesses on
the king's side but i think that's
inevitable the knight can then swing
around to you i think quite like the
smoke
i i said it more as an illustrative kind
of move but i actually the more i think
about it
knight h2 makes some sense
so we'll see what he what he does he has
time to bernie has two minutes still
extra he can also yeah and he does it
okay i like it
so does andrew now have to play g5 or
does he
what he can do also is to take and
something like 97
and get the bishop to c6 but that
involves seeing the center he does go g5
and knight f1 so knee hall oh look where
he's heading he's heading right for that
h5 squad
juicy outpost there definite advantage
here
really nice idea how the knight backs up
to induce g5 and then backs up again to
head for h5 you don't see that kind of
idea very often
indeed and the knight moves backwards
always produce that positive aesthetic
effect
now nihal is spoiled for choice he could
take on d5 go bishop f3
and open up some pressure on this pawn
every move would involve definitely
knight h5 man i cannot draw arrows today
it's actually one of my weaknesses i'm
so sloppy at drawing arrows but you can
also go c5
locking up the center and also going
knight h5 so again it's one of those
things where he's got to make a decision
relatively quickly to preserve
i would say a decently sized time
advantage now very quickly before we
resume our discussion
we want to remind everyone that the
counter refers only to the five plus one
segment not to the whole match so after
the ten remaining minutes of the five
minute portion
the counter will reset and there will be
60 minutes of three plus one
followed by 30 minutes of bullet
and uh dania we're showing this
intricate positional idea
you failed to plug your book i know you
read it a long time ago but
we were just talking about books and you
didn't even remind people that you wrote
a chess book about positional chess when
you were 14 years old right
uh i did i did and i um well
it was it was a great experience i
certainly it's not one of those things i
don't recommend it
to my students even when i think they
should work on their positional chess i
think there have been a lot of better
books written on positional chess and i
truly believe that
but you know the book really was a
formative moment
in my chess development because i
personally learn really well when i
write
stuff down um i think everybody has
their way of learning and so
the book started out as a way for myself
to improve
uh my positional understanding and it
eventually blossoms
and neha well he is showing some
incredible positional understanding here
look at this i mean this black's
position is collapsing your f6 rookie
six
but is that sufficient mike did i is
that called plugging my book
uh well i don't know if it's still in
print if it's not still in print maybe
you shouldn't be plugging it but
it is it is it is and and
it's so awesome to me that this entire
attack was born out of a retreat
movement h2 exactly
and look at where it is now i mean
speaking i mean
black king is going to be out of prince
so now upon to the good for new hall he
can just take another one i completely
agree
mike everything started with that knight
tour at age five
and now look what it is now two pawns
extra and attacking e-holes should take
this home
queen up four to be considered now the
saving grace for tang is that he might
run out of time before he has to keep
defending this position that might put
him out of his misery and if sauron wins
nihal wins we'll be back to three uh and
a half wins a piece with
one game to go probably one game
but probably the way the games have gone
probably won
i wouldn't bury andrew quite you know
one i think to consider bishop b2 maybe
and
and rerouting the bishop in the spirit
of what nihal has that he just decides
to drop his knight back
and retool his pieces he's two puns two
pawns extra so it's not like he needs to
deliver chuck knight
he's sort of casually improving his
position now andrew going for g5 so he
is not
going to go down without a fight here
yeah i sometimes don't try to win these
positions too quickly online because
you want to give yourself two ways to
win one on the clock and one on the
board
you don't want to like go for the gusto
if you're risking anything
and whoa you've got to be careful now
because queen f3 there's rook f6 that
almost drops the queen
but knight f5 i guess i'm pretty sure he
missed that but fortunately as bishop f5
and again that knight the hero of the
position andrew trying to find chances
here bishop h4 he's putting pressure on
that this is
a little bit concerning for nihal but he
can just take the bishop on g6
and swing the queen to d3 so i think
he's fine but now 12 seconds he has got
to be careful in his own right
this would be a heartbreaker if he lets
it slip andrew won one of the pawns back
definitely lost some of the advantage
but now the bishop coming to f4
bishop definitely wants to be on e5
might go there right now we'll see
but it's i mean rook f1 he's keeping one
pair of rooks to preserve the attack
andrew has done a tremendous job you're
generating defensive chances nihal's
still better
but solid solid position and he's
trading now he can take on g3
i think that much of the advantage has
evaporated he has still off upon if it
takes on d5 though
wow okay now chances for andrew queen b1
possible knee hill trying to push his
pawn dropping his request for the
defense four seconds now another time
scramble
another time scramble and he can force a
draw play rook g6 rook h6
he might i think that's what he's going
for but knee hold counter attack the
pawn there's no defense
aha f6 now if you take queen h7 between
h7 he's gonna make a move
one second get it will it be made he did
we'd have five they're both attacking
is it made who's all the results
possible and andrew loses that time that
is lost he cannot move the screen
without giving up the rook
wow but so close game andrew but did not
quite manage
and kudos to nihal they're incredible
yeah i think
if we had our eval bar working then we
would have broken it during that final
time scramble
it probably was bouncing up and down
faster than the stock market
the last couple days so exactly
wow and um amazing job by andrew their
generating chances but
nihal even in time pressure kept that
foot on the gas pedal kept generating
chances and
what a win in our match is tied this is
almost definitely going to be the last
game of the five minute portion
score is three and a half three and a
half incredible welcome to the 6
400 viewers or so this is the opening
round of the 2020
junior speed chess championship
sponsored by chesskid.com
you could call these kid chess kids
although they can all
um you know hang with the world's elite
at this point they're all
uh unbelievably awesome grand masters
and we're we're watching the number one
seed
nihal star who's got his hands full
against the number 16 seed
andrew tang of minnesota the qualifier
however he's fully worthy of being in
this event
absolutely 16c in name only and uh
a player whose reputation precedes him
as both a very strong grandmaster and
a legend of blitz and bullet so
indeed nihal does have his hands full we
we see here a london defense where
andrew has snagged a pawn i'm pretty
sure this is some sort of theoretical
line
it doesn't seem to inspire confidence
now what nehal could be going for is
some sort of lead in development
uh and maybe he will target this v-pawn
now andrew could just drop his queen
back to a4
i feel like this isn't great for black
eye maybe i'm missing
i mean nowadays mike some of these lines
for to a human eye
they might seem you know like winning
but but there's subtleties in the
position that they give
full-fledged counterplay to the
opposition
yeah in the last game the black bishops
were always side by side now they're
side by side again
in fact don you might remember in the
last game the black bishops were on h7
and h8
and then they magically got to g5 and g6
it's like they both move like knights
indeed when i wasn't watching they both
made the l shape
but yeah the compensation here for the
pawn
looks i don't know if it's enough but
i'm sure that nihal must have had this
on his computer and the computer said it
was okay to play
right but that could also be risky and
i've definitely had experiences with
that
where you check the evaluation it says
equal
then you look at the position why is it
equal again and it can be very hard to
just demonstrate but queen v8 might
kneel incredibly strong move
this is a fork and a very deadly one
if you defend the e5 pawn not only does
black 1v2 but the rook is trapped
so andrew might have to give up the e5
but that is a
heck of an important one not only does
he give up the pawn he
might have to move his own king out and
his king will be quite a bit more unsafe
than blacks
nihal could follow it up with rook b8 so
has andrew
blundered with queen c5 is the question
i think he has
yeah usually try to figure out which
pawn to give back and still get a
playable position but as you just
pointed out
it could be that neither one gives you a
playable position and there's no counter
attack on the black king
because famously knight guard kings from
queens
quite well we've seen it a million times
and um there's no way that white can
generate anything against the black king
even though the black king can't castle
that's right and the queen before the
more i look at this might be the lesser
evil
and then going for this position now the
bishop will be hanging in that case
which i missed initially now he goes
like
okay so queen takes e5 is not he has
queen e3
fortunately so knight d2 i actually
really like in the event of queen takes
b2
you're gonna have rook b1 and that black
has got to be careful because rook b7
even immediately becomes a very real
possibility that 281 track could be met
with knight b1
and really it's anyone's game this could
get very very tactical so
we can take c5 definitely the safer
option queen takes b2 seems a little bit
too speculative for me
i gotta be honest with you second
straight time we've had a london
actually third straight time we've had a
london but they've all been exciting
london so
indeed don't don't believe the uh the
wrap on the london system now if we see
a berlin i'm going to say i'm going to
cry foul i'm going to say that i'm
leaving the comments here if you see but
i don't think either of these pledged i
mean andrew is not
you can count on one hand the amount of
times andrew has gotten e1 e4 although
he's
been doing it more recently in bullet uh
so
we'll see wait if you're saying it's in
your contract you can leave the
commentary when there's a berlin i
thought it was a
contract no it's in mike i specifically
bargained for that
clause okay just good to know the
producer yeah no i bargained for it
and they wouldn't budge but you know
then i called up some people i was like
you know
i cannot look at the berlin anymore and
you're you're doing this so i'm not
gonna be a commentator but here we have
a not a berlin game but an end game and
an
unbalanced one as he said mike um i
actually don't
know if it looks it looks good for black
right because of the visual
deficiency and white's pawn structure i
do think white's position is still solid
this knight on b3 does have a strong
hold on c5
one idea for black though skoroxie ca in
the 95 and mount
pressure on this backwards c3 pawn and
he does go 95 first
if the bishops are traded i'll also
point out the knight is an outpost on c4
so problems to solve here for sure
for andrew yeah i was thinking about
this exchange though
you get the c4 square for your knight
but the white knight gets to c5
somehow it feels to me that that's a net
win for white because then the c3 pawn
although it's backward will never be
attacked because there's too many
knights clogging up to c
file so i was wondering if you got white
to play knight c5 if you induced it
somehow
if you would just put a rook on the c
file and play knight d7 or something and
play
without the knights yeah that's actually
quite interesting
and i've seen a lot of model games where
that happens you know they say rook end
games are drawn
but when you have a weakness like that
it can be hard to defend in the long
term
so we do it and andrew's got to decide
yeah basically where he puts his knight
you could also put it on d4 there we go
a solid square but one where it could
potentially be chased away by e5
and don't forget after the five minute
ends this should be the final five
minute game we have
60 minutes of three minute action and
then 30 minutes of bullet action all
with a one second
increment and this is the final 90
minute game so if any
anybody wins this one they will take a
small lead
into the break now do you put a lot of
stock into that final game of each
segment do you think that creates a
psychological effect
um that spills over into the next
segment i think kind of when it's back
and forth yeah because your only chance
to sort of sit
and dwell and really take stock of
what's happened is these two pretty
short breaks that we've got
so um otherwise you don't have time to
dwell on wins and losses i mean you know
better you've played
what a dozen of these matches this
summer
but i do take stock in it actually i
personally
it would affect me is all i can say i
don't know the inside workings of these
players brains and i'm not a sports
psychologist
but um how about you i mean you had a
similar match structure and you're
yeah i mean it's it's the thing is you
know that break
it can definitely do you good or it
could do you harm and when you lose you
dwell in that last game you dwell on the
fact that you had a lead
it did um so i also think it's very
psychologically important now both of
these players we know are virtually
unshakable so
in this particular match i think it's
largely minimized
uh but still one cannot deny that this
is an important game and it is
officially the last game of the segment
as andrew now is it a problem with my
connect okay it seems that he has
disconnected
or is this on my end i'm afraid
i see a red bar here uh a4 was played
rook ac8 and then i don't see
uh rugby c8 and then i don't see
anything happening okay
three definitely the move but i'm a
little bit concerned about android's
internet here
as on my end it shows a red bar my end
too and while andrew is sorting this out
we can take a look at how the live odds
have changed let's go ahead and pick up
pick up our our stock market tracker
there we see the nasdaq
outpacing this no just kidding
the bobble head of knee hall has inched
back
up suggesting that uh that it's just
fine for him to go into the three-minute
segment
with around an even score i i find that
quite interesting
yeah i think neither neither player is
particularly against that you know
andrew says i'm going to keep it close
until the bullet
hole says okay you know um i i stabilize
things i play decently
i'm also very fast so both players are
satisfied okay it seems that the
situation has been fixed and andrew
indeed goes rook a3
so nihal really laying it on here the
pressure
is quite severe but you know the
principle of two weaknesses might come
into play which basically says in order
to win one of these end games
you one weakness is not enough because
the opponent can direct all of his
defensive power
to defending that weakness as we see
here
this pawn on c3 for the moment safely
defended andrew getting his bishop out
and chasing the rook away
this could turn if nihal is not careful
andrew does have some potential with his
pieces
knight could come to b5 although not
immediately and he does have upon
majority which you could start pushing
again you've got to be careful because
b5 runs into a fork
so you have to do it in a very measured
fashion let's see how andrew plays this
the fascinating thing i find about these
end games is you're always trying to
figure out who benefits from a knight
exchange who benefits from a bishop
exchange who benefits from a knight
versus bishop exchange
because those seem to be a lot of the
key questions here the four different
kinds of end games you could have if you
reduce
down to one minor piece for each side
right and i think it's actually very
unclear if you go knight c4 check
who benefits from this because black
does develop the potential of going e5
and chasing the night away but
but in closed positions like these we
know how scary knights can be
the knight could pretend and he does go
knight c4 he takes it to the pawn so
he's preparing for e5 in which case the
d file is going to be open
notice that if android goes v5 and
knight c6 check
that rook on b2 is hanging so that
doesn't work
the knight just doesn't quite have time
but he could go b5 and b6 that does look
very speculative though he drops his
king back to e1
bracing for impact here so that a rook
move to the d-file is not checked
i think a great decision by nihal here
the opening of the default benefits him
the bishop has an outpost on d3
but again will it be enough will he
actually be able to break through
because for the time being he also has
to keep an eye on the possibility of
going b5 and p6
he cannot get too crazy um and divert
all of his resources toward pressuring
white
on the d file well shouldn't nihal play
a6 here because if you stop the a and
the b pawns from moving
then the white rooks don't look too
useful on the a and the b files
i think he did something similar by
going bishop b8 now the bishop is
supervising that diagonal rook d3 is to
be considered here
um sort of a very typical move you and
he takes on d2 so he trades one pair of
rooks but i'm not sure
that that is really the patchwork
getting a significant advantage i think
andrew is bringing a sigh of relief here
again that knight moved backwards the
knight heading for g3 potentially
i don't think nield is worse but i don't
see a clear way for him to break through
he's maybe trying to do something with
f5 and g5
i don't know how scary that is andrew
look at his knight hither and dither to
f3 it goes
nihil stopping it from coming to g5 and
now biting his time to sandra no
definitely nihal still pressuring he's
trying to make something happen pushing
his pawns now
knight two is attacking upon defending
it king e2 andrew shifting his king rook
to d now the rook could head to d3
yep it's going brilliant play here by
niho look at him on all sides of the
board he
is pushing it in and he can't take on c4
because the bishop should be five what a
trap andrew repairing it
repeating the position again a time
scramble
yeah i think black's gonna be able to
move his king to d5 and then maybe
play pawn f4 at some point
i like that idea as well he goes h4
comes at it from the other side
of course andrew doesn't react driving
it to h3 creating a potential weakness
on h2
e4 engine trying but f4 that was that
was a bit of a
hasty decision now things are looking
very very grim that pawn 94 is very weak
nihal could attack with ic6 defending it
is andrew fg though
whoa i think he could have played rook
takes d2 f takes and then the pawn on h4
h3 goes free he could have an fgh that
was a great catch mic but now andrew
pushing his pawn this is not over yet
he's got to take
but how do you stop the pawn rook b8
okay some active counter play for andrew
but will it be enough i don't believe it
will e4
rook c5 the rook c5 oh my goodness have
the tables turned
yeah and the black pawns are stein look
at this look at this this is incredible
mike your move
was probably the cleanest uh shot that
knee hall had and now it might be a draw
amazing now the a pawn is still quite
annoying
uh you're guarding the a6 square so the
white rook has trouble getting behind it
although there are some ways
that's right who is better here
definitely knee hall still pushing this
is practically speaking very hard to
defend with such a bad one you can take
on e4
this might fizzle out rook b4 rook
before wow it
still not that easy but it's still not
easy time to watch the josh fidel video
on chess.com
fill the industry standard on queen
versus rush
wow now does white have a fortress
usually the way this is one mic i think
is some sort of zug's lawn
forcing the king to disattach itself
from the pawn
but it's not easy yeah whenever the
pawns forward you can come at the king
from behind
the h-pawn i think you just assume is
not there that can be won easily
so right i'm not in my table base right
now but i do believe it's probably a win
don't ask me how to do it josh where are
you
yeah hey josh and he's trying he's using
the queen quirks screwing the queen
around now he's shifting the king
it's so hard to find in two seconds you
can also blunder mate here i mean you
can plunder the queen you can mouse slip
this is i mean black's not out of the
woods he's trying this way that way
will he get the king out of the range of
the pawn he does decide to take h2
again as you said mike that's not the
important part though can you get to the
spawn on f5
queen takes h2 was on move 99 so who's
on the count to move 149.
oh my lens that is i mean he left
he's going to make 50 moves here he's
gonna try every which way at some point
you could try to move the king to h4
cause some sort of zoom zone he's done
it but andrew does have an abundance of
extra moves
how do you make progress king being on a
more useful square but it's right
funny how white is never blocking with
his rook on e6 because it's more useful
to keep the black king stuck to the h
file
exactly that's a great point as as long
as the king is cut off queen d5 though
this could be
zuma's long but rook g5 that is an extra
move for andrew rookie six he's done it
now that is progress for knee hall
if he can get a sting to d5 he does now
is it going to be still easy to win
because rook against queen is not easy
to win look at this
expert play by knee he gets his king
into g5 he's going to win the pawn out
he's going to win the pawn
and this is looking grim 30 moves
remaining as i go grab my john nunn book
on the shelf oh it's too far away
continuing how about my barrett's game
manual
he's now he's made a lot of progress it
looks like he's going to win the spawn
he is
and defending this with three seconds
mike a computer can actually do a great
job of defending this
but in a time scramble it's virtually
impossible to defend it as resiliently
as possible
the only trick here mike is some sort of
stalemate trapper the rook gives itself
away anyhow we'll have to watch that
but he is making plenty of progress king
six wins wow
yeah this is actually a computer workout
on chess kid i have trouble being the
computer queen versus rook and he's
still got about 42 moves
remaining before any kind of 50 move
rule there's a key position in the
second
defense where you try to uh you have to
actually lose a tempo by
triangulating your queen right but
actually andrew is doing a good job he's
managed to bring his king
back this might be the content and now i
know i think you stair step your queen
down the a and the b
files right and fork the rook and he's
done it quinn a one queen b1 amazing
in time pressure finding it very nice
catch mike and this is game over and
what a herculean effort 145 moves
by knee hill jumping out on top four and
a half three and a half as the five
minute section concludes amazing stuff
from niholsarin and hats off to andrew
for an incredibly resilient defense as
well
might be the longest five minute stretch
in history because that last game
overstepped
the the five minute section by so much
but amazing 145 moves and if there is a
psychological advantage conferred
by going into the break where they win
it's probably multiplied by that grind
by the fact that you did convert
such a difficult ending so four and a
half to three and a half small lead for
the number one seed but
this this is this is virginia umbc
actually it's not
is umbc beat virginia by like 20 points
in that game but
this is the closest one versus 16 match
up perhaps in chess.com history
and we expected action we got action and
guess what there's a lot more excitement
ahead
as we will soon after a quick break
begin the three-minute portion only a
one-point lead by niho
amazing five-minute section here and we
will let the players catch their breasts
we will catch our own
and we will be back shortly with 60
minutes of the three-minute
portion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
junior speed chess championship
sponsored by
chess kid it is my pleasure to be
commentating along with video master
mike line and we have
the three minute portion coming right
your way but first
a couple of clarifications and notes
first and foremost
the smarter chess match prediction
um mike talk us through what you see
here
and has it aged well in the context of
the five minute portion
pretty close i mean i don't think we got
there in a way that many people would
have thought we would have gotten there
which was andrew being ahead or at least
equal for most of the five one
in fact the only lead that i believe
nihal has had
is through 145 move final game so nihal
was favored
he was favored by two points he ended up
only winning this section by one point
um so he's still in the driver's seat
and you can see he's a favorite in every
section
and if we look at the graph of the odds
to win
he's actually it looks like a little bit
higher than when
the event began even though he only won
that segment by one point
um anyway wait he's creeping up he's
creeping up to back where he was
pre-event so uh i don't know i'm a
little bit surprised by that because if
andrew goes into the bullet down
one i find it hard to make andrew the
underdog and right now
there's no reason to believe that andrew
is going to go into the bullet with any
kind of sizeable deficit the way he's
playing
no absolutely they're so evenly matched
and we just see every single game going
into a time scramble so
to be honest with you mike i you know i
like the concept of these predictions
but
we've seen time and time again it's just
it's so hard to make anything of it it
could swing either way the pendulum
swings back and forth
and we're sure to see some more um
amazing time scribbles in the
three-minute portion so
if you're planning on going anywhere um
you know
not that there's anything else going on
you're definitely staying here because
this is about to get
really fascinating and we have liftoff
here
with another one of these ready sort of
english you know
kind of openings yeah every openings had
the word
ish at the end of it because they've
been more about setups than real
openings so
um 73 chance for knee hall to win but
100 chance that we're going to have some
fun
and we're going to learn something the
big question is when do i switch over
from my chess kid hat to my to my
chest.com hat
so whose hat am i wearing for this
segment you want to go chest back i like
both of you mike
i look good i'm going to go chest.com
but maybe we'll switch back to chess kid
if i'm feeling
quite juvenile later on and here we have
that
e3 g3 setup which i have marked down as
being the same as game five
which nihal won that game i don't think
he won because of this setup but he did
win the game nonetheless
right and he decides to repeat it we've
seen the players being pretty principled
here
both kind of drifting nihal has had a
little bit more variation in his play
than andrew
but they're both drifting to sort of the
same set of setups
with andrew of course playing as usual
his classical repertoire
sticking to the same openings uh but
again the whole taking
the first sort of long think uh and he
decides to release the central tension
with dc we get this sort of hanging pawn
structure here
with the c5 and d5 pawn sort of both
being isolated now the rook
lifting itself i think to d2 in order to
put pressure which andrew curtails with
knight e4
but he takes the foot off of the defense
of the d5
one thing to consider for knee haul here
you could try to trade knights with
knight c3
and um sort of clear the path in
preparation for putting pressure on this
d5 and we'll see
what he does he's done a different
version of the same thing maybe in order
to open up the bishop's influence in the
d5 pawn
and although donya is horrible at
plugging his own book i am going to plug
my own website um
we have all of our lessons structured in
order on chess kid and king level 92
is all about hanging pawns and if
there's one idea i stressed
in that video is you want the hanging
pawns you want one of the two to move
because then that releases the ability
for them to control the other square
and when you blockade the hanging pawns
they're much more effectively targeted
they're wearing cement boots as we would
say in chess kid land so
in many of the examples i showed you
want one of the two pawns to move then
they get stuck and then you're able
to gobble them up so king level 92 if
you have no idea what i'm talking about
go to chesskid.com lessons and you'll
see
what all the kids know about which is
all these great lessons on just kid
absolutely and i agree that i'm terrible
at plugging my own stuff but i am good
at plugging other people's stuff and i
do regularly recommend chess kid
material to my students
um it's awesome stuff so you know if
you're here to get better
it's amazing content and a lot of it on
different topics so i can throw my
voice behind that as well mike um you're
doing some awesome stuff and
need hall seems to be doing some awesome
stuff with those hanging pawns as he has
gotten rid of
andrew's dark squared bishop now the
knight on c4 is now hanging because the
bishop on b7 is protected
uh but where will it go will it go to e5
or will it go to e3 now one thing to
calculate after knight e3
notice that the queen is pinned bishop
takes d4 seems to be possible
it's it's complicated though he does go
knight e3 now andrew with a big choice
on his hands
does he go d4 and seek some sort of
complications i don't see a response the
bishop takes d4 or
does he go something like rook cd8
trying to spring an x-ray
and after the capture is maybe knight b6
but
here you have to pay attention to this
bond something like queen g4 could
strike out of the blue
liberating the queen from the pin and
threatening checkmate a lot of things to
calculate here as both sides now
have used more than half of their time
in andrew going for the latter defending
the pawn
yeah and by the way if black if black
had played knight b6 to defend
maybe white would have played b4
inducing c4 and then we get what i
talked about
which is that you fix the pawns on one
color and then they permanently can't
move and they become targets
and so andrew trying to avoid that with
knight b6 but the queen is a little bit
overloaded here it is pinned a and b
it is guarding the f6 knight if it
leaves
and you have to take on f6 with a pawn
that would be a total disaster given
that this knight on e3
can jump to that f5 square knife f5 as
uh grandmaster feinbuild likes to say
bishop e5 also to be considered here
just driving this bishop onto the
outpost
again we have a situation where there's
a lot of uh promising options
and it's so tempting to sink into a
thought and then
you know have five seconds by the end of
your decision uh so neha will have to
find
it in himself to follow his intuition um
already 38 seconds time flies so quickly
when you're making one of these
decisions
and it's easy mike to be unsatisfied
with every choice because you're looking
for a knockout
yeah hanging pawns notoriously difficult
but my bird's eye view or as millennials
would say a drone's eye view they look
weaker than strong
and in fact they do get captured in fact
daniel i would say the transition to
three-minute stuff
because when you're playing five minutes
for an hour and a half you just you
you fall into a pace and you have to
remind yourself
especially in that first game hey i
can't take 90 seconds on a move like i
was able to in the opening segment
exactly
it sounds trivial but it's not it's just
so hard to mentally adjust
um and there's that cool concept in
psychology i think it's called like
perseveration where
you know if you move to the same to a
different floor in your apartment
building
first couple of times you're gonna hit
the button of that old floor
in your elevator so like your brain
literally makes that connection
uh to whatever you're familiar to
obviously it's on a
lesser scale here but it does exist now
we see nihal has gone for the sort of
materialistic approach he's one upon but
now andrew has sort of gotten rid of the
tension in the center he's traded some
pieces and he's going to go after the c4
pawn it's going to be lost
what does knee haul do here how does he
squeeze the most out of the position
obviously andrew should not take the
queen then the pawn is going to come to
b3 and defend c4 but
which piece does he take c4 with this is
going to be in a very unpleasant end
game
either way and we see nihal activating
his other rook
he can trade one pair of rooks he can
also swing it to a5 and target the a6
pawn
tanya would rather have the extra pawn
which may or may not be used for would
you rather have the extra 20 seconds on
your clock
definitely the extra pawn because this
end game is so easy to play nihal could
make a lot of sort of
waiting moves and gain a little bit of
time out of stock we see here he is
getting right to business he's trading
his double pawn andrew activating his
pieces which is what he should do
he might be going after the pawn 92 this
is going to be hard to win
uh mike especially with 13 seconds what
niho is trying to do
is if brooke a1 he's going to go rook c7
and double rooks on that defile so
andrew has to reckon with that as well
he might have to keep one of his rooks
for defensive purposes on e7 which is
what he does
with rookie seven here we go
okay and black is not wanting to allow
that obviously that takes into account a
lot of losing possibilities by allowing
the the double pac man on the seventh
rank
definitely these end games can be lost
um if you if you over press and we see
nihal
continuing to chip away at andrew's
kings side andrew going for the rook
trade actually that's a great move
forcing the rook trade and this
definitely seems
draws right because the rook on a4 is
very active it is holding down the rook
on d2
still attempts by nihol he can try to
bring his king over to the other side of
the board
in order to free up his rook which is
exactly what he's doing andrew is
following suit we see the canon mouse
game in action here under 10 seconds for
both of them another time scramble
this is going to be definitely hard to
defend objectively though i think it's a
draw
yeah there was a moment after king f5
that black allowed rook d5 it's not that
danya missed it
it's just that it would have lost the a
pawn and then if you put every pawn on
the same side of the board
the winning chances go from two percent
to to nil
and here we see enter continuing to
activate a species rook from f3 to a3
swinging around
uh multitasking holding down the rook uh
on the second rank
the active pieces are everything in an
end game like this
i don't see a way for nihal to make much
progress he's trying to induce zouzovak
f4 can be considered by andrew
the rook on f3 not only is it holding
down white's rook it's also cutting off
white's king
and that is what seems to be the drawing
factor nihal continuing to make attempts
what he could have done is potentially
swung the rook to f4 but that could be
losing that's upon race
and let's see what he comes up with here
it might he might be succumbing to the
inevitable
and we have a draw by repetition great
save by andrew that looked
very concerning in the middle game but
that
decision to give away upon was actually
a very savvy one as the end game gave
him more chances
our first draw since the opening match
we had seven straight consecutive wins
by one player
you don't see that very often but that
just goes to show that there's been
neither player has been willing to to
settle for equality or
to trade down to a boring end game as
either color
and we see another one of these
interesting nimzo indian lines where the
queen is on d5 obviously not hanging
because of the pin uh but yeah it's been
incredibly combative
um and just it's been
[Music]
so close every single game just comes
down to the wire and
we have every reason to believe that it
will continue to do so okay
so penguin now thinking what does he do
with the central tension does he go
knight f3 does he take on c5
he decides to go bishop d2 forcing the
trade and we have
mass trades here this looks pretty good
for black though i think he's definitely
equalized despite white's two bishops
there's one c3 though that's a pretty
big asset for white
now explain because i'm literally not
asking this to set you up i'm actually
asking this based on my own knowledge
okay to set me up white's got the bishop
pair the probably the easiest access to
the d
file the black bishop on c8 is gonna
have to find a way into the game
although i realize b7 looks reasonable
so why do you say that black is fine
when it seems like white's got a lot of
mini advantages
because of the possibility of going e5
right i think that
in a lack of targets and black's
position a lot of times visually the
position might seem better and i think
white has a small pull
but notice that black has no targets in
his position to attack
so it might be a little bit passive but
if you can just weather the immediate
storm
um you'll eventually have a chance to
develop your pieces maybe take on e5 and
go bishop d7
and i think you know 50 years ago or so
people wouldn't go into such a position
but nowadays with computers
with increased defensive capabilities
players have realized that
these types of positions are actually
tremendously solid and they regularly go
into them as black
with that being said i'm not denying
that i think white is definitely
pressing here i like andrew's position
but i think nihal can make a couple of
accurate moves here maybe bishop d7
maybe take on e5 and then go bishop d7
and i think he should be able to hold
all right well computers making their
mark on chess and donya doing well
notice no evaluation bar is really
needed this position is more about
feel and often you know i have this
problem especially in my kids streams we
don't use an evaluation bar but
there's a couple mistakes that a lot of
viewers make not just kids they see the
evaluation go from
1.5 to 1.3 and they're like oh white
white's blown the advantage even though
that's imperceptible there's no
grandmaster in the world that thinks ah
you know i'm probably up 1.5 no i'm up
1.3 that's just not how humans think
and there's also some positions that
frankly computers do not understand
um they think that in opposite colored
bishop end games
that one site can be winning when any
1200 can look at it and say the extra
pawn is worthless
and i could go on and on about these
sorts of examples
um so no evaluation bar today but none
needed we've got
one of the top american players dania
naredinsky and i'm just here for trivia
i know my place
uh and in fact it's time for trivia
we've been talking about books today
absolutely this trivia question is
brought to you by gregory kaidanoff
and he said name a 2700
who has never read a book now i realize
the younger generation
that may count for a lot of players so
here's the stipulation
i'm requiring that you pick a player
above the age of 40.
that's what makes it a surprising ah
okay a former 2700 or a current one
former so don't pick a niche geary
because he's not over the age of 40.
anisha if you're listening hi um and
don't pick a player
who's only gotten to 2500. now this is
incredibly hard
i would guess if you get this right i
will give you all of my wages for this
commentary
can i make a guess or should i let the
ch i should probably let the chat think
about this
you can let the chat yeah let's give the
chat a minute let's go back to the game
and
how about well we'll make uh the end of
this game is when i'll give away the
answer so we'll do a regular commentary
and
that'll give the chat about three
minutes to plug in their answer
pretty good well that's a fascinating
question and
let's uh check back into this end game
as we see symmetrical
piece uh balance here with night bishop
and rook inside bishop north now
still andrew we see knights both knights
being attacked if fva b
and it seems like black's double pawns
are more accessible than whites
so for that reason he helped dropping
his knight back to d5 still a pull
i think for um for andrew here
especially if you can get through the
rook to c1 first
bishop d7 could also be met with knight
c5 hitting the bishop and
drawing it back to c8 uh so still we see
these problems facing nihal but 36
seconds to a minute and 15
that's a pretty significant time
advantage nihal has time
to find a way out of this i still think
he should be equalizing maybe king f7
and try to get the king into e7 but if
rook c1
what can happen is e4 forcing the knight
back and then a penetration to c7 could
happen
that could be a very much unwelcome
sight for black let's see how nihil
solves these problems
i can tell you i won a lot of games as a
junior by anticipating the end game
and already having my king ready now
it's well known
that once the end game happens you
should march your king to an active spot
but
white is almost sneakily getting the
king to an active spot
before some trades happen unfortunately
even if i picture a chess position here
with no pieces except the kings there's
not a lot
that the white king can target uh that's
the sort of downfall of the king
activity
that's exactly right and and that's sort
of the theme right the lack of targets
he does decide on king f7 now my
question is what does he want to do here
against this idea of e4 which could be
very unpleasant
now you could allow the rook
infiltration to the seventh ring and try
to bring it back out with king d8
but i mean as they say that's a little
bit manga s so
i think we'll see e4 or bishop f3 is
also good because if you take it there
we go because if you take on g5
he brings his king in but now this pawn
is a little bit we finally have a target
the question will it be enough um
sufficient
fodder for a winning attempt by andrew i
don't think so because this king
extremely well placed mike to lend
enough support to this point
yeah but still you i don't know i like
this for white a lot your king can march
to d4 or your knight can sit there
forever
it seems like the kind of position you
can torch your opponent but torture does
not always mean
a full point yeah i think there are
certain soviet chess players who would
salivate at the
possibility of position like this but e4
wait a minute e4 looks c so if he four
works c5 takes
if you take back there's a fork because
of the pin right did he blunder
oh i think that was a big chance my
andrew there mike i'm not sure
that was anticipated by neil but he
decides to keep the torture going as you
say
this is one of those positions you can
make a million moves here
i agree i think that white's got the
practical chances i think nihal should
be holding this if he's careful but four
seconds on the clock
it is so easy to blunder or allow
something
yeah and uh nihal just got done
torturing in the final five minute game
in that queen versus rook and
looks like the torturer is going to
become the torturee
i'm not sure those are words but we're
making stuff up here um i'm
you know i i went to a liberal arts
college i'm supposed to know this stuff
but i don't know so am i and i don't
either so we're in the same boat here
okay
mike uh don't don't sleep on the
kingside pawns actually those could
become targets at one point too
and look at him swinging the rook around
and maybe bring the king to d4
and you gotta be careful you can get
checkmated on c4 and b4 is a very
committal move
because you're allowing the rook
potentially to come to c4 g5 here we go
now has andrew over pressed after bishop
a4 he's got to be very careful that
other flank
could cost him bishop a4 now that we're
coming to c2 i think he's got a little
bit wrong he's making space for the rook
to come to g2
oh but now bishop d1 is a threat if the
rook moves okay
dropping his knight back to f5 king e5
centralizing king g4 what's going on
here bishop d7 i think black is better
rook c2
he's taking a pawn like a self-made
puzzle happening here wow
now look at look at black stroke there's
a pawn majority andrew has left this out
of control completely
but he has a passport he's got to push
it oh my goodness and we've seen a case
of over pressing now black spawn runs
it's more far advanced
why does sandwich stand there with this
king this is losing now for andrew and
wow d2 and bishop d5 intercepting the
rook
he's going to promote amazing knight f4
last chance d1 queen that wins the game
he is simply going to give up his queen
take the pawn and win by giving his rook
up four whites passer and niho wins it
unbelievable when um wow
no words mike crazy nice call at the end
nihal takes his biggest lead of the
match a two-game win
and we've had two major themes this
match we've had wedge pawns
and we've also had inability to convert
better positions
white we thought was slightly better the
entire game
and wasn't able to pull it out so let's
hear it for the counter attackers of the
world because
they're the ones getting the job done
today absolutely and andrew we see him
throwing stuff around his room he is
raging just
look at his face he is so unhappy he was
just
banging his table just kidding we see
why he
uh is one of the most level-headed
players out there now mike you made
us a promise okay and i'm not going to
let you
not fulfill that promise so we need the
reveal
of the player who's over 27 and was over
27 who's never at a chess book
could i give you my guess uh yeah you
can let me let me say the guess from the
chat but
then you can take your guess somebody
said kaidon off no i said he was the
trivia giver
okay uh the funniest answer was claude
bloodgood
who um was serving a life sentence in
prison when he got his uscf rating
but he's written a book about 26.90 did
he um
famously did not get invited to the u.s
championship because
he was in prison um he was never 2700
feda although a very funny guess
somebody said paul morphy no we didn't
have ratings back then
so uh nobody got the answer right it
wasn't yvonne chuck what is your guess
donya
i was going to get peruvian grandmaster
julio granda zaniga that's it you get my
paycheck
we actually had force a draw just got it
believe it or not
how did you know julio grande zuniga was
the answer
so i've actually played him a couple of
times and
when i was playing him and the first
time i played it was 2011
i did some research while i was
preparing for the game and i found some
stories that he was one of the most
unconventional
one of the most unconventional paths to
the top where he basically had never
read a chess book i read some interview
with him
in preparation for my game with him and
i ended up playing him twice so i have
some
personal experience so it's not like i
it's that impressive i just played him i
did some preparation and some research
and uh this is the exception that proves
the rule everybody out there
chess books are good um as are lots of
online learning resources of course but
i guess the good news well i'm happy you
got my question right i wasn't rooting
against you but that does confirm the
trivia question
by kaidanoff that julio granda zuniga
of peru who did make 2 700
in this decade or i guess i should say
last decade he just barely got above it
i never read a chess book but uh pretty
amazing stuff well
mike i miss our trivia nights at the uh
castle chess camp in atlanta
the geography uh trivia so that is um
that is something we'll have to recreate
that's an awesome question
i asked the players before the
tournament name a hidden skill that you
have
and nihal wrote back to me and he said
that he knows
quote quite a few world capitals oh
i i'm going to have to test that now if
i may appoint myself as the ultimate
tester of that
i will um i know you're awesome i think
nihal may have been underselling
not that we should take wikipedia with a
grain of salt but if you go to nehal's
wikipedia page
it says that he could name 190 world
capitals
and country flags by the age of
three oh my are you did you see
three now this is wikipedia i don't know
how we're going to be able to confirm
this
i think we're asking that question in
the interview yeah nihal if your parents
are in the chat mr and mrs sarin
um i don't know how life is in carol of
these days i hope it's great tell me in
the chat if in fact this story is true
are you kidding me that i mean now nihal
was already impressing me before but if
this is even halfway through
even if you knew them by the age of nine
that is
incredible yeah we'll we'll give them
some some tough country
capitals yeah let's think of some
burundi i mean
gotta think of some good ones all right
so
we have asymmetrical pawn structure
equal material in the ending and we have
the white rooks bearing down on c5
although if there's one strong point in
black's defense
it is c5 i guess one of the questions i
would have is is white preparing b4 or
d4 yeah he definitely is um
and by the way one one potential trick
is to ask him a country that whose
capital has recently changed such as
kazakhstan
and i think there were a couple of
others as capitalism i think uh don't
quote me on this but burma or myanmar
uh that uh capital has changed recently
as well anyways
um to answer um your question
i think he is preparing b4 in order to
potentially carve out and he's not
trying to win the pawn on c5 so much as
he is trying to carve out
that d4 square for his knight what black
could do is simply not react for example
if you go before i could drop my king to
d6 and this pawn on c5 is very very well
protected
um why could still put the knight on d4
because of the pin
but again it doesn't do much so andrew
potentially
eyeing the possibility of creating a
passer with h5
um so let's see how knee hall handles
that and now a nitrate on the cards
which would seem to get a relatively dry
shank and what nehal could do is go king
f3 rook h2
and actually target that on um so maybe
he does have a slight pull here
battle of the rook end game so far in
the three-minute segment
and not sure what the odds are so far
but nihal's been doing just fine in the
three-minute
um you know we've been making a joke
about not wanting to be the better
player and not wanting to be the person
pressing
i'm not sure who i like in this end game
it might just be that they each have a
weak pawn and they're going to toggle
let's see they neither one has been that
willing to bail out into a draw and
there we go e4
uh knee hall not happy with the
repetition and is going to go for a
passer with e5 i think
and look at those pawns now the one
drawback of that right is this f4 pawn
is a little bit weak and could be
targeted with rook
h to f8 but even if you do that there
might be a possibility of going f5 check
we'll get into that if it happens in the
meantime nihil sidestepping the pin
he's preparing something like f5 against
maybe he's preparing f5 even without
rook f8
andrew trying to cut into that pawn
failings with h5 very good move
maybe f5 should be considered here by um
nihal
let's see what he does very very
structurally complex position he does
play f5
i really like his position you look at
these puns notice the pin
uh does not allow black to take on g4
here he takes on f5 now he takes f5
would create the possibility of rookie 6
check andrew going after the pawns now
rook g6 is going to be very powerful
this is going to be a devastating move
rook g6
intercepting blackstroke uh mike this
seems to be spiraling out of control
train him like h4 i'm wondering if you
trade and play h4 just to prevent white
from getting connected passers okay he's
actually just going to give definitely a
practical chance yeah but now maybe g5
even rook takes h5 simply
and even if black takes you get not pass
pawns but two very far advanced funds
spoiled for choice is knee hull he does
go for this also b6 is hanging
this is definitely losing for andrew i'm
not seeing even a way for him to get
practical chances
maybe he should go after the pawns as he
is king f4 or even king h4
to prevent the rook later on from
stopping upon with rook h3
should be considered so nihil definitely
thinking about that two to one time
advantage as well
he can also looking for him king takes
e3 take the other rook
he goes king h4 okay let's see
h6 and maybe rook to g3 to intercept
black stroke
is what he wants let's see i think rook
g3 is what he wants
he does yeah and the rook's got to go to
e1 and e8 only
well i thought that was the only action
that they know it's nh7 king g5
incredibly well calculated andrew has
got to activate his past
his passwords but not fast enough and he
resigns amazing end game performance by
neo and now mike
this is getting concerning for grand
master tang as a
three-point lead has been opened up by
nihal sarin exactly knee halls won
four and a half out of the last five to
go from a two-point deficit
to a three-point advantage maybe i get
my math wrong there
yeah i think he was actually only down
one game so he was down one
now he's up three thanks to having an
undefeated final five games
and uh don't know what the match
predictions are looking like now but
i would have to say that nihal is
probably up above 80 percent
we'll see if smarter chess can confirm
that and this is a pivotal moment this
is where andrew
has got to stop the bleeding there is
something unsettling about being down
eight to four right you're almost
lapping your opponent
um and if you win a game here it's only
two points to me
mike and i don't want to do overly you
know over prediction but it seems like
andrew with the white pieces here
has to try to score a victory and there
we go there we see the
the talking head of nihal sauron
continually inching higher
and he's climbing a mountain while
andrew's down in the valley
so uh rarefied air for the number one
player the 16 year old getting the best
of the 20 year old
thus far how much uh you know you
covered the entire
knockout how much was andrew challenged
he had three matches on the knockout
stage is that right
yeah and it was extremely close in all
of them okay uh particularly i think
and don't quote me on this the second
match against uh van
nuyn from the czech republic was very
close it was back and forth now we saw a
little bit of nervousness from andrew in
the beginning
he was even losing a couple of games on
time um
but then by the end he kind of settled
into his groove and
the final was an incredible display uh
by angela so
he's one of those players i actually
played a match against andrew
a couple of months ago as part of my
series of matches
and at one point i was up i think five
or six points going into the bullet
segment which was actually 30-second
chess
and andrew mounted a comeback he won
five in a row and he
brought the lead back down to one so he
is more than capable of it by the way
what happens if nihal takes everything
and then takes on c5
using this pin against white's queen i
feel like andrew may have blundered here
let's see
i think he blundered that this is very
concerning now
we had another b pawn that was poisoned
there after c5 black didn't even have to
take a half a second
to avoid queen takes b3 where bishop d1
would have become a problem so just
another queen trap
we saw that i believe in game one of the
match
black wasn't falling for here nihal too
strong for that
exactly and um andrew definitely has
recognized that he could take with the
bishop but that does not help
something like this might be the lesser
it will also look at the d5 square
that is a huge blockading square for a
potential black knight that could
swing itself around to d5 so positional
advantage as well on top of this
this is highly highly unsettling for
andrew now as nihal goes for it
and he can now swing his knight around
from d7 to f6 to d5
shutting the doors on any counter play
connected with this active bishop on b2
i can see andrew touching his face in
his lips though that's about as
concerned
as it looks like he gets is that some
sort of certificate in the background
is that like his grandmaster probably i
see always in his streams
okay maybe intimidating his opponent
with his feed agm
cert except they've all got it that's
the problem we've got 16 players in 16
gm
now this would be bad even if nihal were
not up upon this is a disastrous
disastrous position look at all of
black's pieces harmonious this d4 pawn
is on the verge of collapse
and andrew has got to pull a miracle
here in this game
to try to get this match under control
to stop the bleeding
um yeah and he tries to go into the
opposite colored bishop end game
but the promise is not an end game
there's rooks and the queen's still left
on the board
i suppose there are some drive
tendencies but it looks like like he's
going to lose the spawn on d4 as well
yeah and uh although we've not had a
scandinavian any member of team scandi
will definitely appreciate the pawn
structure for black
because this happens a lot in that
opening where you plant your pawns on c6
and e6
and you target the d4 pawn the
difference is white usually at least has
a c
pawn to defend it and now that c pawn's
been chopped out
it's like team scandy on steroids
so a bit of a strange illusion but i
think the pawn structure does bear
mentioning
no definitely we had one
opposite-colored bishop middle game back
in game two
that andrew tang won but this is not
that game there's no queens on the board
we're closer to the end game than we are
the middle game and the d4 pawn he's not
getting any safer
he's gonna be weak from now until the
next morning
indeed indeed and um well andrew
may be hoping that that um certificate
is going to give him some strength but
wow and i mean john bartholomew like you
said mike team skandy he would
love this position i mean hey guys john
let's just take on d4 here we got some
black gate going guys
all right take on guys yeah but this is
like a dream scenario now again
if you take on d4 with the bishop the
one issue if you move the bishop away it
could lead to a trait of rooks
[Laughter]
and we are zooming in look at look at
the camera angles here
amazing stuff we're trying to get a
sense of um
i think it's the fide logo i mean it's
got of what it says
all right andrew can you just move your
face a little bit uh yeah it definitely
is something feeling related
okay and by the way i think it's the gym
side it's got to be the gym certificate
john was one of the first coaches i
believe of andrew although
john is not going to want to watch this
position this is not what what what you
want um
now black is the gm certificate i can
confirm this is what mine looks like too
sorry go ahead oh this is what my feed a
pin looks like
my f my fun master pin it's the only fun
master pin in the world i assure you
don't look at it too closely
black can play pawn to e5 here
supporting the bishop
thus trying to avoid the mass trade of
rooks and by the way sometimes people
say
fun master mike how'd you get that name
dania it actually happened at the castle
camp
because i was surrounded by grand
masters all the kids were asking me one
day
hey fm what's that stand for
yeah it stands for fun master and uh
not it just stuck so interesting i i
didn't know that that's pretty cool and
um
i like it fun master mike has a certain
ring to it now here's the problem for
richard now if me hall trades rooks
that could still be losing for right
look at these funds they're all on dark
squares
and here we go nehal still not training
them he's using his king in a very savvy
manner to take upon this is definitely
losing for white on top of it andrew
six seconds he's desperately trying to
create something
but nihal is simply too solid here a6
training pawns
good try but i'm afraid it's not gonna
be enough this king could also
infiltrate to f4
and again keep the rooks on the board
give yourself two chances to win you're
gonna win either on the clock or on the
road
there's always that small chance if you
trade rooks that white can set up some
amazing fortress
uh but keep the rooks on the board okay
now the rooks are gone
but i don't believe there's a fortress
when the black king is so active
and you could go a5 you could even
preserve the other pawn not that you
would need it
he goes bishop h4 i i don't know why he
didn't keep the apon honestly but
this is a kind of famously winning
endgame the strategy is
you move these pawns and without the
pair of b-pawns sometimes this is a draw
because the bishop would give itself
away for two pawns obviously here
even if the bishop does give itself away
black is going to have that b-pawn
remaining so this is a very elementary
win
this is almost checkmate as you can see
white cannot hold these pawns together
they are going to push
um whether white likes it or not and i
think we're about to see another victory
when the pawns are side by side you
should always push your pawns
to the light squares because they'll
have no trouble advancing
to the dark squares so for all of our
fans that are listening they're a little
bit new to bishop end games watch how
black keeps doing it
there's no problem getting those pawns
to f2 and g3 because that's the color
you control
if you would push the opposite way a
blockade could be set up
and once again black does it for the
third time black
well he's about to i forgot we're in
analysis mode but yeah yeah and there we
go
that is official he promotes does knee
hold eight to four ladies and gentlemen
as this is spiraling rapidly out of
control with 27 minutes left
in the three-minute portion andrew has
got to make this a little bit closer
i still think he's the favorite of the
bullet i think that is his chance but
with how good nehal is i mean it can
he's got to bring this at least to two
and get your hi-hat drums ready because
andrew is bringing
messed up the joke andrew is breathing
sarin gas
we're waiting to say it i think now is a
good time to say it is a good time to
say it
five and a half out of the last six for
the young superstar from kerala the
number one seed
showing why he deserves that title it
was very close for the first
85 minutes of this match until nihal won
a queen versus rook
pawnless ending in the final game with a
five minute
and then he's taken three and a half out
of four in the three minute
indeed indeed and uh uh be as the game
is in its opening stages let us remind
you very quickly of
what these players are facing off for we
have some amazing prizes at
every stage uh we can see that
basically the winner of the finals gets
uh a cool 2 500 and what might be even
more important for the players
qualification to the
uh speed chess championship and uh
also important to notice is that all of
the games will be played even if the
match is decided
uh because a percentage of the prize
fund
goes based on the actual match score so
there is always incentive to win games
even if the actual results of match has
been decided so a lot to play for here
and these players mike are just putting
themselves on the line
yeah so we're not going to see anybody
that's mathematically eliminated play
the grub or anything like that
unless they unless they don't care about
the 50 bucks that they're losing by
by losing to a higher match percentage
so
50 bucks to kids these days is important
um it should also be said that these
players are not
making anything in over the board
tournaments right now because they
haven't existed
so um you know internet chess is a
bigger and bigger deal
it really is um and um it's great to see
you know the adaptation process taking
place so quickly in a very very
difficult time for us all
um so many opportunities for these young
players who of course
the progress of many of them is
curtailed by the absence of
um over-the-board tournaments very very
difficult on so many players who were
at the apex of their chess careers using
this time to gain rating and to
to become grandmaster so not an easy
time but
you know it's good to see chess.com
doing as much as it can to offer
opportunities for
these young players who are hungry for
competitive tournaments
an interesting moment that just passed
us by the knight took on d4 however if
white had taken with the pawn the white
pawn would have been blockaded so easily
that is a completely unideal isolated
queen pawn position
so white is instead opted but for taking
with the pawn keeping the pawn
symmetrical
but you can see how his pieces are
invading nonetheless now wait a minute
here bishop b5
speaking of invading is nihal simply
winning a piece there because notice
the knight cannot move the bishop will
be dropped so white is attacking that
bishop and i don't see a good way to
defend that knight
bishop c8 i'm not going to consider
looking knight c6 this is going to be a
disaster so
i'm pretty sure that nihal is trying to
figure out whether andrew has anything
up his sleeve against bishop b5
right off the top of my head i don't see
anything now there is a weakness of the
back rank that white has so there might
be some sort of hidden tactic here
but if there is i'm not saying maybe a6
and then bishop d6 trying to get white
to look out but even rook takes b7 leads
to two pieces for a rook
at the very minimum and i'm sure there's
better than that so nihol taking his
time here
but bishop b5 actually might be a
crushing blow and if he wins this game
that would be a five-point lead
andrew you can't read anything by his
facial expression but
mike he does seem to be a little bit
unsettled here he just threw himself
back in his chair in a way that suggests
oh no
what you know what's about to befall me
um knee hall looks about as intense as
ever not in a menacing way but
in a man that you could tap him on the
shoulder right now and he may not even
react he's
that glue that's it he's locked in
knight takes e6 is also a move with
queen g4 to follow
a lot of threats here so now that i'm
looking at it that might be sort of a
quote-unquote safe for alternative and
he does it so he goes for knight 66
beautiful idea here by nihal with queen
g4 to follow now the point is
after fe queen g4 and that's what he was
calculating maybe there was something
about bishop b5 he didn't like i don't
blame him because
you're threatening mate and you're
threatening the pawn on e6 but it's not
about the pawn
if you take that pawn you also fork the
knight there's a million threats looming
another thing to notice here now the
king walks into a pin boom queen takes
h6 goes the dynamite with bishop c4 to
follow
this looks like a complete disaster for
andrew this that's pretty brutal and i
would almost argue that
in a situation where both might be
winning he might just be trying to
figure out which one is
easier to analyze and this may be easier
you had to show a couple of different
variations after bishop b5 that were a
little tricky
here it's very forcing because bishop b5
uh it's not as threatening as knight
takes e6 because
you're hitting the rook and you're
hitting g7 i don't see what you do if
you don't take this knight you can't
allow knight
i was thinking briefly about knight to
c5 trying to
kind of entomb this rook but again it's
so deflating because at the very minimum
white can give this rook back up and
he's up upon i'm sure that that is not
the best way i can do
but maybe that is the lesser evil for
andrew i don't know
um perhaps knight c5 has the effect of
muddying the waters nihal does have 32
seconds so andrew looking desperately
for some way
uh to make things a little bit
complicated
let's see what he chooses yeah i was
almost wondering if knight c5 if you
could go crazy and play queen g4 and
that's not a very good game management
move
but after knight takes knight rook takes
bishop on e7
threatening rook takes the knight and
yeah and you do have back rank mate
covered
um again i'm not sure if it's the best
from a game management perspective but
it might work
out um so for anybody at home quote
cheating with your eval bar on
[Laughter]
yeah and he's gone for fe but one second
for andrew and he succumbs to the
inevitable this actually might happen
queenie and and he goes king h7 to avoid
but now
e5 can come in with queen g6 to follow
that is just going to be immediate
checkmate i think
uh for for knee hall he goes queen f5
first and then e5 i think will follow
we're going to see a resignation from
andrew if that happens he doesn't even
have to do that he can go
yeah and he does beautiful beautifully
conducted attack when he holds so smooth
and a five point lead mic with how much
time left i think right around 20
minutes left we're gonna
confirm that in a second in the three
minute portion it ain't
it's never over till it's over mike you
referenced before the biggest comebacks
ever made in the speedchest championship
could you remind us of the range that
has been
uh you know that people have come back
from
yeah uh there's been at least one four
point come back and at least one
five this was confirmed by smarter chess
and this is
this is jogging my memory back a long
time i believe the five-point comeback
was turned in by international master
yaakov norwicz
who beat the chicago grand master
of course my my mind would blank uh of
rook
yes boris was the opponent kind of
surprising but you know norwich is known
for his internet chess
i believe that was a five game comeback
now interestingly
in crush against tatiana kazinseva
crush had to win her final five games in
the bullet
and i think she beat kazinsva by one
game so it was it was a
literal last chance come back
and uh unlike every other nice story
about charlotte
tatiana kazinsva played her match
at the charlotte chess center so it's
about
the one negative thing we can say about
the city of charlotte today
and the chess center is an amazing place
as well so
um play your matches for the cello chess
center
so uh so it's going to take a historic
comeback
let me ask the chat because we could
speculate all day things were close
up until the 90 minute mark what do you
think
has changed in this match to allow nihal
sauron to win six and a half out of
seven i'd like to hear
from our chat you guys get to be um our
mock commentators
in the chat uh let me know what you
think was it an opening choice was it a
time management choice
was it something else because you've had
the luxury of
pontificating while we've been trying to
talk our way through this maybe you can
let me know
absolutely and we thank uh the thousands
of you who are still here with us
watching this fascinating match unfolds
i have a feeling that there's a lot of
action left i'm not going to put words
in the chat's mouth but
um i have a feeling that there is going
to be some
intrigue here as we have an interesting
slop so
looking forward to seeing people's
opinion yeah it's it's a great question
what seemed to change because it seemed
to be so subtle and all of a sudden boom
five point lead yeah and maybe the
sample size is too small to make a
definitive
um statement about why i mean in fact
the funny thing is were it not for the
draw
in game nine knee hall would have done a
fabiano
and by that of course i mean win seven
in a row but if you were to ask why did
fabiano win seven in a row in 2014
i don't know i mean the sample size is
pretty small he's always been fabiano
um but maybe there's a reason there
sometimes is a collective threat as to
why
that was crazy fabiano that brings back
some amazing
memories another memory that i had of a
comeback in the speech image which was
not
technically speaking a historic comeback
size-wise but
match between jan krishnaf duda and
alexander grishok
i think rishik was up don't quote me on
this and i've said that multiple times
but really don't quote me on this i
think it was up three points
with like five minutes left in the
bullet and judah came back and won four
in a row it was fun
i was watching that from the charlotte
chess so the charlotte chess center
seems to be involved
in some way shape or form in these
comebacks
maybe i should make my way to the chess
center right now i'm pretty close
i do remember that match you don't you
would not have expected the veteran
i'm not going to use the word collapse
but to allow i kind of come back but but
grisha is a very
uncompromising player there's not he's
not the kind of person that says
hmm i'm up three i'm going to change my
openings and try to manage this match
i mean greece shook he he gets what you
think he's going to give you that's why
he's so exciting to watch
indeed we all love sasha and okay i
tried to win the match but okay
young christoph came back a little bit
but okay this is kind of what makes me
strong so
but okay here we will see what andrew
can bring to the table
um but anyways uh we have nehal with 40
seconds now this is actually a shot for
andrew
he seems to have a good position despite
is he down upon no he's not down apply
so nihal's pod structure is definitely
something went wrong for him in the
opening andre has great central control
let's see if he can activate his pieces
that knight on c1 is a little bit
stranded this knight on a5
is pressuring the b3 square so um
andrew yep he's protecting d4 he's
preparing queen c2 and rook t1
15 minutes left in this portion and i've
got to believe that andrew's got to get
this margin down to at least three games
is that five
right now but uh i think three is the
number that he should be
he should be shooting for definitely
three is definitely surmountable so
he needs to take this one game at a time
maneuvering here but nihal has
of course so strong in bullet as well
and just the way he's played here he's
fast i mean he's calculating swiftly
he's not making any careless mistakes
and here we see him actually sacking
upon
and he's probably just trying to open up
the c file for his rook maybe cement the
bishop with a5 at the end now the
problem is
at the end of this line this knight on
v6 could end up being hanging
and d5 could follow so he's got to be
very careful about that
um i'm not exactly sure oh what he wants
is to take on c3 and go bishop a4 and
pin the rook
wow what an idea i'm telling you he's
finding some incredibly creative ideas
but andrew taking the ball on a7
sidestepping that minefield so
definitely
big time advantage here for andrew and
almost no time remaining for anyhow this
is
a game that he simply must carry home
yeah and the annoying thing for black is
that you always have to look for the
center pawns advancing
like every single turn it's going to
burn time on your clock
one of the other problems with your
opponent having what we call in chess
kid land the snow plow
the two pawns side by side in the middle
because they tend to push stuff out of
the way and there we go
the snowplow uh by the way you did snow
in colorado the other day somehow that's
happening in the world in september
and uh the snowplow here amounts to the
bishops breaking through the rook has
come up and over
and some sort of queen c6 rook takes h6
ideas in the offing
all kinds of fun for the white pieces
absolutely queen c3 is also an idea at
some point threatening rook takes h6
mate and i like that you have names for
these things that
we all kind of know but don't have names
in standard chess nomenclature
so the snowplow indeed serving andrew
well here and now he's got all sorts of
mating ideas
h5 brilliant positional game thus far
he's just got to take it home
nihal is so hard to bring down and here
we see he's creating some threats so
rookie 8 would win i think on the spot
uh but there is some stuff to calculate
queen for
andrew choosing to place him oh rook
taking c66
carlson karaoke and final game of the
world championship was rook takes h6
and there we go exactly different
position here but rook h6 wins another
important game
it does and andrew brings this to four
now
would you say this is another must-win
game if he is able to win this one
that gives him even some time in the
three-minute portion so important game
for both players here as nihal goes back
to his trusty
retti with b3 is he going to double
fianchetto again he's won some nice
games in that line he's gotten some good
positions
andrew this time trying to curtail it by
playing bishop g4 now playing g3 doesn't
make much sense
because of this pin yeah you're asking
for trouble i wouldn't call it must win
because i look at the match clock with
12 minutes
and i think this is probably going to be
this game and
maybe two or three others so i'm not
going to go so far as to say must win i
know we use that term a lot
but it would be nice to win it'd be
really nice if your name is andrew tang
by the way you said something
interesting about the fact that we have
names for things i think it's really
nice for kids to be able to say ah
snowplow stuff like that but i'll also
say that you don't have to have
funny names to be good and i'll tell you
how i know this
i was on the set for gary kasparov's
master class
and he actually said when he learned
chess in russian they did not
differentiate between
pin and skewer yep they don't they still
don't
they just called line attacks he said i
actually this is hilarious
i always have trouble even in my streams
i i confuse the two even now i will say
skewer when i mean pin and pin and i
mean skewer because in russian there's
only one word skasca
that describes both uh both so fun fact
i can totally contest that because i
also learned chess in russian
um and there is indeed only one word for
both yeah and decoy deflection they're
all kind of the same thing
so you don't necessarily need to know
the terms however
when you're making funny videos like i
do which is pretty much my whole life
having a snowplow go across the screen
has a little bit more memory for a kid
than um than just using a big
four-syllable word that's exactly right
and
decoy i also i always say the word
distraction which i don't think is a
formal name for anything but in russian
that word for decoy deflection literally
means distraction
um so i always use that but i completely
agree with you mike and it could really
help i think kids learn positional chess
when you have you know somewhat fun
names to refer to things
they can sort of more specifically
understand certain content so i think
that's fantastic work and
it really is uh it's awesome now there
is one time danya where you have to get
the word right
and this is a fantastic story when uh
when when hillary clinton was secretary
of state she was meeting with the
russian secretary of state
oh it is sergey lavrov and she was
trying
to tell her counterpart hey let's reset
relations with our countries
and she accidentally had one of her
assistants that spoke russian
misinterpret a word which is a chess
word
uh i believe the little button that she
presented
said perry perry gruska instead of perry
zagruska
exactly she was telling her counterpart
i'd like to overload relations not reset
relations so can you confirm though is
the russian word for
overload perigruska peregregruska yeah
so you can say
like uh fierspirigren like the queen is
overloaded now
but the thing is the word pity zagruska
is so is incredibly rare
so it's already asking for trouble like
that is that is a very
like abstr you know kind of an esoteric
word that's not used often
so it was already a weird choice to
begin with and russian is
it's the kind of language where you can
switch around one syllable one letter in
it
and it really changes the meaning of the
the word i do remember that story
actually
yeah and we've got national master and
chess kid star
brewington hardaway the former top 10
year old in the usa
has joined us in the chat we're probably
overloading him with russian language
lessons
so back to our game we have a
symmetrical pawn structure a little more
space for white and what i see
are very strong pieces in the center but
i like the white knight on e5 even more
than what than black's bishop on e4
yeah and what niho could consider
playing f3
and drop and then this bishop on d5
we've seen this before it could actually
get sort of stranded in the center
uh so andrew actually well we have a
train and nihal is definitely pressing
here look at this knight on the two we
could jump to a5
and it could start frustrating black's
pawn so the sort of symmetrical position
does not tell the whole story andrew has
some work to do
in order to draw this and hold his own
he could consider trading rooks and then
defending the pawn one thing that could
happen
the trade works and go b6 the knight can
start hunting down these pawns let's see
what he does
this has happened so knight c8 is
interesting i'm not sure that it gives
enough to be able to
generate true winning chances but this
is going to get interesting for sure
and let me just queue up brewington
hardaway here chess kid star who do you
like in this position burrington do you
agree
with the analysis or do you want to go
your own way i'm going gonna let you
type in the chat
i'll read whatever you type in
probably a little too early for for
match management but this game has gone
on so long
last time i took a look at the match
clock we had dipped below eight minutes
it's very possible
that there will only be one more three
minute game
after this one and if you're the leader
generally you do want longer games that
shortens the number
of remaining games in the match so i i
think it's still a little early to do
game management or match management in
the three-minute segment but it
certainly doesn't hurt nihal that these
games are going so long
uh-huh interesting and and by the way
this king from f1
it could walk all the way to e6
potentially
using those light squares as a
passageway and applying pressure on
black spawns
so let's see what knee hall comes up
with andrew pressed to the back of the
wall here he's kind of paralyzed but
i'm curious what brewington what
brewington thinks about this position as
well
yeah and actually that's a funny reason
why you may not want to play knight
takes b8 soaks soon
because after knight takes it does cover
the a6 square so maybe you wait for your
king to get to a6 before you take now i
doubt that black is just going to sit
there and allow all that to happen but
the knight is in no hurry to take the
bishop on b8 yeah it's incredible how
paralyzed black is he literally cannot
dislodge the knight from c6
he can't move the knight can't get the
king to attack the knight
this and f4 further restricting black's
position stopping ideas of 95 is knee
hall now he is saddling himself with
this potential weakness
but if you go e5 look at this position
incredible
andrew might at some point have to part
ways with one of his queenside puns but
that is a disastrous loss in an endgame
i think he simply lost
i think that this is simply winning for
white yeah black is really
not able to find any space here by the
way brewington does concur
he likes white more and if you want to
play brewington he plays every saturday
in the month of
september on chess kid go to the chess
kit calendar and see when he's playing
next however
what we're focusing on right now are two
of the best grandmasters in the world
especially when it comes
to online chess but we see nihal seren
looking to put the match back to the
five point margin
indeed and just one more shout out to
brewington i had the privilege of
commentating the
um danker and rockefeller tournaments a
couple of weeks back and
i was quite impressed with brewington's
play throughout the tournament so
definitely a shining star of american
chess best wishes to you
uh on your path and here we see nehal
taking the king's path to c4
he's going to take one of these pawns
the bishop is going to drop back to f2
in order to restrict black's king uh
from coming to h4 here we see a pass
pawn being created
this is definitely completely winning
for white black's king is simply not in
time
he's too cramped the e6 pawn is weak
black is on his back foot on his last
legs
this pawn is running this game is over i
agree
we remiss if we didn't say that the
reason that white won the pawn is
because the knight was perry's
perigruska it is a yeah exactly this is
perigruska very much yeah
and another win here for niall extending
this lead pushing it back up to five and
quite possibly the last game like of the
three minute portion is upon us
right they will parry zagruska the
pieces for one more game
in the knights we'll go back i only know
two russian words they happen to be very
complicated russian words but
uh a five point lead nobody's ever come
back from a greater margin
than five points um and it looks like
they're the odds
are 86 i'm actually surprised they're
not higher
but 86 percent odds for nihal sarah and
that means he's going to win
approximately
seven out of eight matches where he has
a five point lead of this segment
i'm really surprised we're not up above
90 percent i'm not saying
i'm gonna lay eight to one odds on
andrew or anything like that but
i'm just a little bit surprised because
i don't see anything that suggests that
knee hall
would not be above 90 but smarter chess
has the numbers i just have the
guesswork i don't actually have the
ability to to do the math no i think
it's actually
i mean and neohal taking his time here
on move too um
get the camera back up on the players is
he having some sort of
i mean it looks like his internet's okay
you know what's funny is if you have
like an emergency restroom situation
you i mean you only have to lost one
more game before the
the break but no he's there why do i
have some stories about that
so finally he makes a move now this is a
pivotal game in terms of the odds
again if andrew wins this four points is
very much surmountable for him
if nihal wins the six point lead i mean
anything is possible but this is i mean
this is really i feel like potentially
be the match deciding game so andrew
with the white
pieces we know how dangerous he is we
have sort of a symmetrical
a queen a4 check there is a move i'm i'm
not too familiar with this line i think
white is slightly better if he goes
knight c3 as far as i know
um and they do go into this end game but
i'm sure any hall is very well prepared
and it can be very frustrating when
you're trying to win an end game like
this and you feel
the advantage slipping away from you
let's see uh whether andrew will be able
to put pressure g3 is an interesting way
to develop the bishop here
fiance may be putting more pressure on
black another request in the chat for
trivia that seems to be my main utility
in commentating
i think i only have one question left
and besides we can't ask trivia during
the bullet so
i'll go ahead and final my final
absolutely my final trivia bullet here
this is probably the easiest question
i'm going to ask you but
we asked all the players before the jscc
began
which player would you most like to have
dinner with
past or present so alive or not alive
i'm so used to saying kids shows we
don't say the word dead but whatever
all right pastor present so again we
couldn't quite get our questions to
andrew tangentine because he
disqualified so i have the answer for
nihal
type it in the chat who do you think
nihal sarin would most like to have
dinner with
you're probably not going to be
surprised by the answer which is the
biggest hint i can give you
hmm that's it i
think i could take this in various
directions i could i could see it being
vishy i could see it being fisher i
could see it being
gary um
i mean there's so many mouth-watering
guests who could have at the dinner
table
you know one guy i personally would love
is mikhail tal
who was incredible uh just character in
addition to being of course a legendary
chess player
but i'm very curious mike i actually
don't know uh can i give you my favorite
mikael talk quote
please do when he was told about a
soviet-era plan
to eradicate alcoholism mikhail tall
said
the state against vodka i'll be on the
side of vodka
and of course that was part of his
undoing but what an amazing player and
we might not see a player that creative
again
because you could simply do stuff back
then that's not possible today i mean
bador jobova
and grieshook and they're all trying
their best richard rapport
but mikhail tall will always be the
industry standard
for creative chess uh nezmetanov too but
i think
mikhail told he did it with success more
than any other player
exactly and he's always been my idol you
know
as i've tried to go crazy a couple times
but he is
he's a legend and uh you know one of
those people who was a man of the world
you know he had so many interests and
very well read and you know
just uh there's an interview with him
that has english subtitles from the late
80s toward the end of his life
and he shares some fascinating insights
into his lives and stories and uh
you know you just got to cherish people
like that and what they have brought to
the table
and there's a trick here if rook b1 i
think knight takes b2 might be the idea
book takes b2 and then you take and it
is a fork
now castles is possible yep and you
avoid that because then the king can
take definitely andrew with the edges he
has fianchettoed his bishop
which makes it very hard for black
bishop to develop without giving up a
pawn
maybe black needs to part ways with that
pawn anyway rook d4
definite pressure being put by andrew
knee hall also with 30 seconds on his
clock
so this is this is looking good in the
early going here for andrew as he can
bring his knight to c5 also
yeah one of those rare times we actually
castle right onto the open files but
again you can't play chess on general
rules you have to take the demands of
the position
and see um you know what rule applies or
needs to be broken uh black's got some
development problems here with the b7
pawn being so weak yeah
and also you know white can consider
bringing his rook into the game with
rook hd1
white needs to be careful his pawn
structure he's got a lot of pawn islands
his pawn structure isn't great
so bishop v8 here would be possible by
the way and then maybe drop the bishop
back to c7
i actually quite that seems rather
mouth-watering uh but he doesn't have to
he can also just double rooks
um and as we've discussed he's got to
make the decision quickly keep that time
adventure i i do like rook hd1
because then you could bring the rook to
the eighth rank and black's pieces
are in a lot of trouble the bishop and
the knight are both undefended he does
just that
we all know the quote the threat is
stronger than his execution so you keep
it should be it in your back pocket
you could play bishop v8 even here and
if rook takes v8
there's a back break mate uh so but this
is just for show i don't think that it's
actually any good
could have played bishop b in the last
move and then gone back to f4 i once uh
going back to gregory kadanov he once
taught a two-hour class about why you
should always repeat once
now i never knew that you could give two
hours of reasons but he didn't
wow it was awesome i really enjoyed it
yeah
okay donna's lectures are amazing i had
such a good time in the u.s chess school
taught by kaidana
he's awesome he's a good guy and a great
teacher and his life story is amazing uh
confirmed this is the final game of the
three minutes so if nihal
sarin manages to win
he's not winning but if he manages to
win he will go into the bullet with the
biggest
the most insurmountable lead that
anybody's ever come back from but he
looks like he is losing
and big win for andrew bringing the lead
to four points it
is still a very big lead an amazing
performance by nihol in the three minute
portion as our score is officially 10
points for knee hall 6 for andrew as the
three minute portion concludes
um what a turnaround here what a
performance by nihol but andrew winning
the last game
and um he gives himself at least mike a
fighting
chance yeah he wins two or the last
three he stood up right away and
i actually saw nihal either talking to
himself a little bit or shaking his head
up and down maybe somebody in the room
was just confirming what this score is
so four points is still going to be
an unbelievably tall order when you're
playing the number one seed but at least
we still have a match
and if there's one thing that andrew
tang is synonymous with
it is bullet and so he's walking right
into his best discipline
indeed he is we have 30 minutes of
bullet coming up for you we will see
whether andrew can find it in himself
to mount an incredible comeback or
whether nihal will deliver
the hammer blow but first we're going to
rebuild our coffees and the players
will refill theirs we will go on a short
break and when we come back
30 minutes of bullet as the final
portion
of this incredible match is upon us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
the
junior speed chess championship brought
to you by chess kid
we have the final portion uh the bullet
portion of
nihal sarah versus andrew saying an
amazing match uh coming your way
very shortly but first let's walk
through um a couple of details first and
foremost let's take another quick look
at uh the bracket mic and see
what mouthwatering matchups we have
coming up starting
uh tomorrow i believe with grand master
raunak sadwani
uh competing tomorrow so mike any
thoughts about
what we see here on the bracket um
not to correct you but i believe on my
schedule it says eragassi is playing
google's
yeah my back my bad it is very guy
you're right the winner of this match
will play smirnoff versus sadwani and by
the way
whenever that match happens we have the
most adorable picture
of smirnoff when he was five years old
so you're going to want to tune into
that match
just to watch that picture but tomorrow
exact same time 9 a.m pacific
noon eastern 5 p.m uk 7 p.m for my
friends in vilnius
you will see aragossi against gucash
another great match
and then if you really um are up late in
australia
and you want to watch your boy smirnoff
play sadwani you have to wait till
september 23rd but
um we've got a month-long action of the
best juniors in the world so
a lot to look forward to absolutely and
to take another quick look at our
statistical prediction we have seren
predicted to win the final against sam
seven we see here and a very impressive
performance thus far in this match so he
is indeed making a case for himself
uh but we know how unpredictable things
can be every single one of these matches
uh is going to be so incredibly close
and they are not just playing for honor
they are also playing for very serious
prizes
uh as we remind ourselves quickly the
winner of
the whole thing gets a cool uh two
thousand
five hundred dollars and a ticket to the
coveted speed
chess championship itself uh but we see
everyone gets a prize
500 750 for the winner of round two
guaranteed
um incredible prizes and we see the
players
putting their blood sweat and tears on
the line for every one of these matches
uh as we transition back and we will
have liftoff any second on 30 minutes
of oneplus one and a herculean task mike
awaits andrew
who has to surmount a four point lead uh
that nihal seren has currently has
and nihal is also one of the greatest
bullet players in the world
yeah he dug himself a big hole with
about a 30 or 40 minute stretch of
substandard chess or at least
results-wise
where nihal got that big lead by winning
six and a half out of seven
you take that away and andrew's actually
got a small lead in the match andrew got
himself back in the match
by winning two and a half excuse me two
out of three to close out the
three-minute segment
he has a four-point deficit his biggest
deficit
was actually five and that has been
surmounted before
in a previous match of this ilk several
years ago so
everything to be decided and even if
things get mathematically
out of his hands you're still playing
for prize money because the margin of
victory
does matter for all of our matches
absolutely um and uh that's what makes
these patches so fascinating uh
you know and and just your body we will
play even if the match is decided
every game is played in the allotted
time limit because part of
uh the prize is determined of course by
the match score so
buckle in for 30 minutes of action and
here
we go with yet another uh kind of ready
structure
and andrew has got to play for a win
with black with white he cannot afford
to kind of
trade baskets right he's got a he's got
to get some black games here as well
exactly no time for an analysis board
either everything's going to be shown
live we probably will expect at least
eight bullet games
sometimes you see as many as nine or ten
uh the players are so fast though
that can actually elongate the games
because they can play
90 or 100 move games because they're
they're so good with that one second
increment so i wouldn't expect too many
what i'm trying to say is i think andrew
needs to think about going six
and two i think six and two is the
number you shoot for
and then you hope for the best in a tie
break um i'll need a refresher on the
rules do we have do we go straight to
armageddon or do we play a couple of one
plus one games
i have a feeling we play a couple of
oneplus one games but we'll get that
confirmed
uh by the production crew but i think if
andrew even gets the tie break he i mean
he'll be you four again
he'll cross that bridge when he gets
there yeah so we have confirmed we have
four more games of one plus one
in the event of a tie and if that is
also
tied then we go into an armageddon match
right five plus three but we're you know
we're just basically
we're letting you know because it will
happen at some point in the next month
that may not happen today
right and uh exactly so we have andrew
with a nice position you better get 20
seconds he has led his clock
dip and we know he's not afraid of that
but against knee-hill nego knows exactly
how to pose problems he's playing a lot
faster we have h6 g5
now white doesn't have a knight to stick
on h5 this time at niho closing up the
position
and preparing a queenside pawn from this
has gone a little bit south here for
andrew
i like neal's position and very little
time remaining on the clock
easy play for white as he begins to
attack the queen side black gearing up
for e5 i think black would have
preferred to play d take c4 a long time
ago and try to play against the hanging
pawns but
i guess he did not like the space
advantage that white conferred he gets
his e5 in but here comes the passer
and rook takes is not allowed because of
bishop b5 with the world's
worst pin slash skewer depending on your
russian language terminology of all time
exactly and now that pawn on c6 like a
splinter and andrew
trying to retail his pieces this looking
very very bad now
he's got to make anyhow use some of his
clock which he is does he take on e5 and
expose that d5 pawn is the key question
rook to e3
ah what an idea rook to e3 andrew going
after the spawn on c6 but now all of his
resources
are tied down but what does nihal do
bishop a6 wow and now bishop takes the
80s one in exchange
the game far from over though andrew has
a plan on a piece he's trying to
activate his queen but he gives up d5
this is looking very very rough now a
full exchange up for very little
compensation
andrew's got to whip something up but
nothing seems to be on the cards his
bishops are simply too passive a5 now a6
is hanging
the rook can come in to see seventy hull
going for a queen trade
look how carefully he's converting that
king is perfectly safe it has the h2
square
uh this seems to be essentially over uh
barring some sort of
a miraculous blunder by knee hall one of
those weird positions where
you have just enough thought that you
could make a comeback where you don't
resign but it's gonna cost you 30 more
seconds of match clock and there he goes
he finally resigns
in a five point game now basically
must-win territory truly must win
territory for andrew
there is enough time 26 minutes left
they will get at least five games in
probably more
but every game needs to be a golden
performance now for andrew
you want to put much time there right
mike i think yeah my prediction will be
seven more but that means you gotta go
six and one
but not much yeah as we said crush
against kazinseva would be the
the model comeback that we're looking
for where crush won the final
four bullet games to i think beat
cozensva
in the playoff but the point is you
don't really want to rest your hopes on
having to run the table
we would call that dormian golf you
don't want to end up dormy as black
where you have to run out
to be able to survive right and it seems
that andrew isn't doing very much to win
this game he's simply worse than an
in-game i think he blundered something
there
now just to remind the fans here we are
not obviously we are not rooting against
nihal
uh but simply obviously we we do want to
see intrigue so
it does not come out of a bias but
rather because
um you know we obviously are always
looking for a comeback
but not to take anything away from
nihal's performance so far which has
been
absolutely incredible to have such a
score against
a bullet and blitz wizard as such as
andrew is a very very impressive
performance indeed
we had a quick splash of the real-time
odds still
exactly 86 percent for nihal quite
mysterious to me because
he was at 86 percent about an hour ago
with the same five-minute margin you
would think
the same margin with less time on the
match clock would make his odds go up
but the point is 86 percent so however
those numbers are derived but
uh the point is uh i still think it
should be above 90
like i thought the first time indeed
and um wow i'm just impressed that nihal
is holding his own ear in the bullet
this is going to be a dead draw which of
course favors neil he wants to bleed as
much clock as possible take that one
away otherwise it goes to h6 tricky move
by andrew but not good enough
and uh yeah i mean
this is probably going to be a draw one
thing i would try to do if i were now
maybe andrew is now worse he's by the
way he's down two pawns mike
this other rook coming into d2 now he's
the one who has to make a draw
um and he wants to do that as quickly as
possible trying to give himself as much
time
as possible to continue the match so
frustrating because
you have to burn another minute of match
clock and just hope for the draw
now i've heard of people saying in
situations like this probably not this
situation but
that you should just go ahead and resign
but mathematically that loses another
half point that you have to recover
which takes time to recover so i don't
actually believe there's really any
scenario
where you should try to resign a drawn
position to save match clock it's
it seems very unlikely to me that i
don't ever want to do that mate it's
right on the board
but rook d8 i was going to say now wait
a minute that was a very tricky idea
andrew but niho finding the defense here
look at how carefully
he is defending he doesn't mind a draw
um but i would go for it yeah and
the reason he's doing this is because he
can simply bleed another minute off the
clock with that increment
um he can all there's nothing wrong with
it he's not doing anything dirty he's
trying to win this position which is by
the way not an easy draw on h5 wins the
game
andrew blundering h5 and this is
disaster as he will lose this one as
well
and double whammy as nihal burns more
and more time
mike this is the kind of territory where
i would already consider resigning
because actually saving this objectively
is going to be very hard yeah
unfortunately we did not get to see the
king and 2 versus king and 1 technique
so white was correct if your goal is to
try to draw to keep the rooks on the
board because at least you can check and
maybe create some confusion but you're
right it's ultimately lost
and that would make it six match point
uh margin which would be uh of historic
proportions
if white was attempting to make a
comeback white being andrew tang
indeed now i may have spoken too soon
andrew trying to kind of tie his rook to
that pawn on e6
is he going to hold this together at
this point it's not quite a moot point
but rookie
two so he's trying his best but does h2
and black's idea
to give up that each one for the e pawn
and that is a theoretical win if it
happens
i don't see a defense here for android
because now rookie one you take e3
he resigns six point lead for nihal and
now with 22 minutes left
he's got to score a couple miniatures
and although nobody's really been asking
i did leave you hanging on the last
trivia question nepal wants to have
dinner
with vichy i mean was he really allowed
to say anything else i mean first of all
i don't think he's just saying it um you
know
vishy really has that kind of stature in
the indian chess world
in fact he's not the only player to give
the answer vichy
we'll release those as few future
matches come out but
here we see a crippling of black's pawn
structure
is andrew a player that goes on tilt uh
or
is it a is i can't even say his decision
guys he does i mean everybody does at
some point when the frustration reaches
a boiling point
i think he's a lot less prone to tilt
than most um
and even andrew's tilt is you know not
comparable to
tilt of other players you know myself
included i'm capable of playing on h4
and a4 and move one and just
slam stuff or andrew you know maintains
a cool head but
sometimes there's this middle ground
between tilt and frustration where
you're not outwardly tilted but you're
just your
quality of play goes down as you're
another bad position
another blunder you get into these loops
and i think here we see
one of them look at nihal's 3365 rating
i mean that is not a fluke
that is how well this guy plays um and
uh
this is again spiraling out of control
is andrew losing some pawns
the king side incredibly weak as well
wow 33.65
that's not a chess reading that's a rush
song that is just amazing to get your
rating up that high
another mate on the board but queen g4
covers the bishop with check and now
we'll probably see
well he's probably worried about g3 and
then rook g8 or something like that
right but then queen
h5 may be threatening checkmate now that
does create a pin so something like this
the bishop cannot take the rook because
of the pin on the queen so black could
play rook g7
problem is why it's okay just having
that position so
andrew trying to go for tricks here and
he's succeeding this is interesting now
but oh the matrix and the thread of the
rope look at that
and andrew loses this one all of a
sudden the rook on seat is hanging
and mate is threatened and he resigns
another one
and he resigns another one three in a
row for the south indian superstar
and um so far andrew not able to show
his best form
in the discipline that he ostensibly is
best known for
yeah and now we we talked about this
in the beginning of the match mike how
much do you think the increment is
has impacted this match uh in retrospect
um that's a great question i mean
definitely in the five-minute segment
the players were playing in such a way
where the increment was important
because they were willing to bleed their
clock below a minute
still in complicated middle games so i
guess the genesis of your question is
how differently would they have played
the slower time right without the
increment i don't have a great answer
for you
um so i'd like to turn this one back on
you because i
actually don't know enough about the
players to say how they would have
played differently in the five minute
i think some of the time scrambles would
have probably gone andrew's way i think
he's still marginally better in that so
that i think favorite nihal
um but again it's it's uh it's always
interesting to me how something
ostensibly small
can really create a big impact or not so
it takes age three
takes h3 indeed in queen h1 if you so he
snaps upon off the board now
white's king again very weak b5 well
that then they would follow knight a5
but definitely nihil once again in the
driver's seat
um as andrew's london is on fire h5h4 is
another idea here
to try to get this bishop on g3 off the
board and weaken
white's king's side further going back
to your question
adding the one sacrament chess is
basically a game when you reduce the
time control
you're adding sport and you're lessening
science right
like we could have the most accurate
game of chess ever played if we gave the
players 24 hours per game
so adding the increment basically says
we already know these matches are played
incredibly fast to make them more sport
but we're adding a little bit of science
because we want players to be able to
convert winning end games
and we want we don't want random we
don't want people sacrificing their
queen for no reason
to to nullify a pre-move to win by a
half a second
right so i appreciate the increment for
that reason because we're not judging
reflexes we're still trying to judge
chess and the balance for me is perfect
with the one second increment
i think that's a fair point and i think
that if you know we like the time
scrambles and we
have them it's not that one point a
second increment eliminates it by the
way i think you invented a word
did you say sacrament because that's
like a
second ending increment i like that way
that's like what do they call it
portmanteau
yeah i think i think i uh sometimes i i
think i have a speech impediment
sometimes when i'm
speaking because i'm trying to say
things as quickly as you're moving them
on the board i'm just trying to keep up
with you
no i feel you completely it can be it
can be tough but i actually like that
so i agree we see the time scrambles but
we also see
very very high quality chests even in
the bullet as we see knee hall this way
and that way he is feeling out white's
king side
f5 is on deck and that is just going to
destroy the last line of defense here
bishop takes f3 to follow if the knight
moves potentially
um this is not looking good once again
for andrew and you know sometimes when
it rains it pours it can be tough to
watch it can be tough on a player when
it seems like nothing is going right
um so you know one has to just feel feel
andrew's pain here but
with that being said knee hall is is
playing just a fantastic
match with every move black is giving
white something to worry about and white
has not gotten a chance to get his pawns
mobile those pawns are sitting there and
not bothering black and the least and
the
black pieces are either making a check a
capture or a threat
virtually every turn exactly and another
threat there
there was a check bishop b2 being
threatened andrew is defending this
really well though
he is up a lot of pawns but the attack
still rages on
one second though for niho let's see if
andrew can score oh
and he gives the rook ah and another one
bites the dust here andrew
defending very well he's trying to get
him with this queen but now everything
the roof comes off another night is
and everything is captured here now a
bear king and andrew resigns another
victory
resounding by knee hall as he inches
toward 3 400
bullet that is incredible pretty amazing
stuff an 8
point match lead mathematically it's
going to be
well i don't know what kind of math i
can invent to make this work we're gonna
have to
uh we're gonna have to like you know
what what's that kind of chess where
we're gonna make like the three-point
contest where the final couple games are
worth two points or something
we'd have to change the scale but they
are playing for money it's real money
it's a split of five hundred dollars so
um
right now it's two to one it looks like
333 dollars
extra for nihal and 166 for andrew
wait it's not two to one it's fourteen
to six okay andrew please win this game
so the math becomes easy
right exactly yeah
no this is and by the way okay so queen
p2 your knee hole again look at the
pressure that he puts with every move
you brought this up in the last game
mike
there is just this sense that he's
playing with as my coach would say
playing with energy you know every move
creates a threat creates problems now
there's problems on
the c5 and on the diagonal he's
threatening bishop takes c6
that this is actually a crushing move
and he's threatening bishop takes g7
amazing uh so all of a sudden it's such
a peaceful looking position
we've seen him do this a lot of times
all of a sudden creating
what seems to be insurmountable problems
now bishop f1 attacking the queen
g7 is going to fall and that is going to
be
what seems to be virtually another
crushing blow
wow yeah in fact it might be two pawns
after bishop h8
because you have to play queen g6 you're
right yeah but then rook c7 might come
in perhaps so bishop h6 he does
something similar
now i would just drop the bishop back to
f4 sit on my extra pawn and the wii king
the rook can come into c7
queen queen to a3 look at the bishop on
f1 sort of incurring the king's side
completely h5 andrew trying what he can
but i think white can go after the pawns
now and then at his leisure play h4
and a lot of pride in andrew's game here
being such a good bullet player i'm sure
he wants to scoop up some wins
not just for the extra lunch money but
to remind people of how good he is and
bullet rook c8 first move that comes to
my mind here
completely agree i think that's a great
move trading forcing the trade of brooks
queen a4 though i think he's
prioritizing stopping h4 as the queen
controls that square
uh and and you're absolutely right
andrew is is
a legendary bullet player you know i
think he's a little bit off today in
some regards
but yeah as another pawn collapses rook
a5 can now be met with queen e8 check
saving the bishop so three puns now uh
for uh for knee hall
i do think this was good for nihal's
ultimate tournament chances by being
tested
in this opening round i know that the
final score won't reflect it
but don't forget he was down for much of
the five minute
um and it wasn't until the transition of
the three minute where he started to
open up a lead
um so i think that's nice now
i want to question you i know the
matches were played a couple of days ago
but do you think andrew he's 20 years
old could he possibly be a little bit
fatigued or are these players
so used to playing so much internet
chess that
three matches several days ago has no
impact on a friday match today
well to answer your question i think
fatigue is one of those things
from experience that strikes when you
don't really
you don't feel it on a surface level you
think i'm pumped i got some sleep
i feel good but then you look at your
play and you can just sort of see
the signs of tiredness and you see the
you know the sort of occasional
uncharacteristic blunder so it's a very
insidious threat
um and that's that's the scary thing
about it
um you just sort of you know the
adrenaline
seems to replace uh it seems to make you
feel like you're awake and alive
but it's just inevitable these processes
that wear you down
uh they just kind of take place whether
you like it or not so i absolutely think
that is uh an issue i also think andrew
is incredibly resilient he plays so many
of these incredibly long matches that
take
hours and hours so he's pretty much
primed for that but
these are some very very high stakes
matches and uh it can be hard to
maintain the same level for sure
by the way in the opening game we never
got to actually show people why e4 did
not work for white
white actually had a second chance to
play it but again it didn't happen
now the difference between this and i
believe the very first game
is that white played rook c1 before the
black queen even got to c2
not that queen c2 was winning but it
certainly was complicated for white to
figure out what to do with that queen
so that's the main difference between
this and the opening round game
good point indeed and uh now a solid
position for andrew but it is also for
nihal again we see that weakness of the
king side
and in bullet i've always felt like that
when you make a weakness on your king
side that's always accentuated and it's
not a particularly deep point it's just
harder to defend and bullet
so like every little deficiency can be
amplified uh because of the just limited
time you have to defend
congratulations to all the fans of nihal
sarin i bet you're still up in the chat
it's almost
1am in india so uh thank you for
not netflixing and chilling and instead
watching the end of your countrymen
uh nihal sarin is going to take this
opening round match the question is
by what score and by how much money and
could he possibly
have a perfect bullet against andrew
test
i mean that that would be a feather in
your cap to be able to say
that you ran the tables in the bullet
against andrew tang
indeed and this game looking good for
nihal again despite his time
deficit look at his pieces all of them
playing bishop before rookie four he's
going to double rooks if that happens
um andrews king is also under fire
um and indeed for nihal playing very
late
uh continuing to maintain such a high
level is just incredibly impressive
bishop c7 going after the pawns
now what's the pawn count i think andrew
was technically up upon but he's going
to lose it i think f4 is going to be
captured
this does look defensible for white but
boy
is it wow if if niho runs the table on
the bullet that will be
just an unbelievably impressive feat
against andrew
he is down two to one as far as time so
i seriously doubt it will happen
because even after this game we've got
at least three more i
i mean how can you put your money on
andrew losing three or four bullet games
in a row
regardless of what's happened to this
point but uh but we'll see i guess
that'd be as close as chess
comes to like a perfect game in baseball
or something right and i think this one
i think
uh andrew does have a chance with three
seconds of the clock for me although his
pawns are very
very concerning okay takes this might be
a draw actually i mean it starts to
liquidate
on an h4 though you have to defend it
maybe rook h2 he gives it away
okay so he gives it away but he
activates his pieces i think nihal might
just force a draw here
i mean there's really no need unless he
is trying to whitewash andrew yep in a
draw upgrade so
there we have it what a disappointment
mike neo onyx i mean this is rejected
draw wow i mean terrible performance to
show didn't adopt andrew come on
to show you what i don't think 16 year
olds can adopt they're not of legal age
to show you what kind of fighting match
we've had only the third draw in 22
games you've only had one draw
in each of the three time controls
that's pretty low
uh when it comes to we'll call it
deathmatch standards i'm showing my age
when i use the term death match we
haven't had an official death match
in about two or three years but uh yeah
19 of the 22 games
have been decisive and unluckily for the
minnesotan
or i should say the minnesotan uh the
the young player from kerala is doing
well
absolutely he is and we've seen him
repeating with great success
this particular type of line where he
can get us either one or both bishops
ready structure and he starts to harass
blacks on center
as we see andrew trying to counteract
his activity by deploying his queen
attacking the bishop attacking pawn
but um yeah so now a decision to be made
by neo as he defends both at the same
time guarding his bishop
uh but you know we'll see if andrew was
able to score an honorable or two as we
are down to
eight minutes left in this incredible
matchup and uh
mike i'm just so excited this is only
the beginning we have so many
more awesome matches uh to come so i'm
really
just excited to be here and to be
commentating and uh
hopefully we've still got oversea you
know we've got thousands of you still
watching whether it's late in india
we really appreciate it so big shout out
to all of the
fans uh cheering on new hall and andrew
here
as we enter the final stages of the
match and
uh in the most self-deprecating comment
of the day i could say that if i was
knee hall here i could even win this
match and i say that because
you could literally let your one minute
expire on the next
five or six games run the match clock
down to zero and still win comfortably
but
they are playing for money they're
playing for pride all of india is still
watching
so thank you for not watching jay leno
or whatever the
the up at night late um indian version
of that show is and we've got some
tricks on g7 here we do bishop g7 here
is really strong followed by queen g4
and then bishop on g7 will be
independent
knight takes g7 preserving his bishop
that is equally as good
double whammy there with the rook 98 is
possible as his knight h5 look at this
knight
swinging around it nights at close
quarters like this with the king being
exposed
are so dangerous and we see it here
andrew will have to give up his rook
i think four night queen g4 followed by
queen c8 as possible rookie one is also
possible involving the rook as he does
impossible to defend this with three
seconds queen g4 check oh and he's got
queen g4 rook takes c7
sacking the queen for me let's see if he
finds it he does
andrew running with his king taking on
e6 he goes for the business approach
just
extending the attack look how many
threats there are
okay bishop f6 but andrew holding on
he's still holding on but the problem is
nihal is also up upon so even if the
attack one of
fails will no longer look at andrew
escaping to e8
he's extending this game
yeah you always have this hope of
playing f5 knight moves bishop d6 okay
he's going out about a different way
but he was trying to get his bishop to
c7
and nihal sort of simplifying but now
andrew's up upon
or no no it's still equal so he was up
two points actually so this is still
better for white because of the weak
black king
nihal recovers one of the extra pawns
and another one of those situations
where he can play this for
for an hour and bleed clock not that he
needs to do that
because of how overwhelming the match
score already is yeah
five minutes remaining in this match so
we'll see a few more games after this
and um if you trade queens the players
can pretty much shake hands right away
which could happen right here yep
and despite the extra pawn of course we
know opposite colored bishops
greatly increase the drawing tendencies
not always there are exceptions to the
rule
but here black's king is in the right
place and
white just doesn't have enough to make
the draw and they will agree any second
bishop can simply tie itself to on b7
and no progress is possible
yeah and sometimes you're so caught up
in the middle of the match you're not
even thinking
we've heard players before say that the
idea of milking the clock didn't even
enter their head
because they're just so caught up in the
moment or that even though it's
completely legal they don't believe it
that they view it as unsportsmanly um
i once played an over-the-board
tournament as a kid where
my opponent at the beginning of the game
got sick and had to go to the restroom
and i went up to the tournament director
and i asked him
am i supposed to stop the clock because
my opponent is sick
now the tournament director happened to
be our dnd master for dungeons and
dragons
his answer was well that depends mike
are you chaotic evil or lawful good
and actually that was a perfect answer
because there's no rule that says you
have to
although some people view it as
sportsmanly however i would argue at
internet chess
not that there's a lessening of morals
but that the clock is such a part of the
game
that using it in any way legally to your
advantage
is aboveboard completely agree with you
mike i think that
there is sort of like a border you know
there's stuff that is questionable but i
agree i think that
you can allow yourself more online than
over the board and i think that there is
a general acceptance of that among
you know among players uh i think that
they usually don't
take objection to these kinds of things
um and players have different views on
this some
are more into flagging some are less but
there is a spectrum and i think that
usually
i always think that when a player does
anything to win
it can be obnoxious but usually it's a
sign of respect and
in the sense that he really really wants
to win so he values the opponent so much
that he
will do anything to beat him you know so
he really it's important for him to win
so it can be thought of that way as well
not that you know there can't be
obnoxious behavior
there absolutely can magical wizard01
says that he or she cannot see the score
because it's restricted and he or she is
on his school computer
now i don't know how you're accessing
the chat i'm very proud of you but also
a little concerned as a
former in-school educator that you are
skipping school but you're probably at
home i actually don't know what's going
on in the schooling world but let me
just tell you a magical wizard
it's 16 to 7 in favor of nihal sarin
against andrew 10. we've got two minutes
left
it's possible this is our final game but
they'd have to play a lot of moves
probably we'll see one more after this
yeah yeah and uh we have
actually andrew mounting a tremendous
attack here against nehal's kane all
trying to trade queens
you can consider even a sack on f6 now
the problem here for andrew is okay he
trades queens but the end game is
completely winning look at his pieces
and messing together there
on the king side uh but yeah i mean
crazy stuff going on right now but we
appreciate people finding the time
not that i advocate uh doing this
instead of paying attention in class
i would never do such a thing mike i
would never encourage people to
procrastinate by
watching chess and in order to figure
out who is going to be the next star of
the chess world in 10 years that's chess
kids job
chess kids job is to get more kids
playing chess so we can eventually see
them on chess.com
and if any of you out there are
educators or parents you're involved in
your school pta
you're a principal wait a minute are you
a superintendent of a district
if you are please email schools
chesskid.com
we will make sure that every kid in your
district is able to get access to chess
and here's what i want to see i want to
see rook b7
followed by a3 bishop rook before me oh
look at you and he goes for a slightly
different mating now
this is as effective because he is going
to pick off that knight
hole and now take all of black's pawns
and uh knee hall yeah so this is over
now again i think you're doing awesome
work with chess kid and uh
i'm very passionate about the cause of
bringing chess to to everyone i think it
helps in ways that perhaps people don't
realize now you know a lot more about
this than i do mike but to me
people always try to measure or just
chess make you better at math scores but
i think chess builds so many skills that
are not always quantifiable
by a test i agree you know so many kids
grow up playing team sports and they
have to win or lose but they can always
sort of diminish a win or a loss based
on teammates but in chess
you're all out there by yourself you've
got to fix all the problems yourself you
did some great work in the bay area
we're happy to have you as the resident
grand master at the charlotte chess
center
and that game was finished with 14
seconds left
so it is i'm not going to call it bonus
chess
but we should be able to squeeze one
more game in because there was
definitely
time on the clock and andrew gets his
first win in the bullet
right in the penultimate game indeed in
a very good game there with an attack
keeping his
his coombs cool uh now
we will i think that the players are
probably not aware the time has not
expired yet now we'll see
it looks like they might actually be
done
let's see they definitely there was time
remaining
okay they are done so looks like the
players have agreed to end the match
here
and a score of 16 to eight in favor of
grand master nihal saren who defeats
grand master
andrew tang um so
what a match by nihal winning all of the
sections incredible show
um as things somehow got out of control
for andrew
um by the three-minute section
yeah nice to see him come back there
though i feel good for him that he was
able to win that final game
now he's done like 100 game bullet
matches against magnus so
i'm sure he doesn't need the pad on the
back i'm sure that would feel
a little bit like i was uh some sort of
evonucular commentator
um but uh indeed yeah so i think
um we're gonna just stay right here as
we're getting the
interview or are we going on break i
think we're going in a very short break
uh and when we return we will have these
two gladiators
for you and we will have some questions
and we'll have the interview so very
quick break
and we will be right back don't go
anywhere we have a really interesting
interview
coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen we
have grand masters neil sieren
and andrew tang here for you for a quick
interview
um right after the match nihal
congratulations on your victory
fantastic play
uh there was a point in the match when
things kind of turned around
and you won quite a lot of games was it
sort of a conscious change
uh did you sort of change your approach
as the five-minute section drew to a to
a closer did you feel like you sort of
just got more warmed up walk us through
how you felt throughout the match
and yeah the match was very close
throughout and
um the five minutes was very tough for
me
somehow andrew was playing extremely
well and
very fast and at some point i was just
trying to
not get so angry at some point it just
started going well for me and yeah then
they're just good now nihal a few days
ago
when you saw that andrew tang won the
knockout by winning all those matches
and you found out he would be your
opponent you could make the argument
that this is the toughest
one versus 16 match up ever for the one
seed
what were your thoughts when you found
out that andrew tang would be your
opponent
yeah yeah it was i knew it was going to
be very tough and
andrew is of course very fast and strong
and yeah i'm a big fan of him
i see you smiling andrew dude did you
know he was a fan of yours
i mean you played many games but
that's that's flattering um what about
those three matches you had to win in
the knockout to get here andrew
um i don't think a 20 year old would be
tired out by matches especially when you
had
several days it's not like you played
them yesterday but was there any fatigue
from those matches
i don't think so if anything it's like
early in the morning i just haven't
quite woken up yet
that makes sense are you surprised that
you did better in the five
minute i mean i'm sure you went into
today thinking you would win everybody
would but
you know your result your results were
better in the five minute
do you think that's an underappreciated
part of your game
yeah i think okay i'm not so bad at puts
but of course i expect to do better when
the time is lower so yeah well
well you played very very well one final
question for you nihal
um do you sort of prepare very intensely
for these matches or do you kind of keep
a clear head
where on the spectrum do you lie
i don't prefer so hard for these matches
but i do
check a bit and
um i hate to ask you a gotcha question
but don you and i
see donya seems to think that if we had
a competition on world capitals
that he might be the favorite but nihal
i don't know if this is verifiable
your wikipedia page says that you knew
190 capitals and country flags
by the time you were three now first of
all is that true or is wikipedia
being a little bit generous with that oh
i don't exactly know when i was very
young
maybe i knew a lot but now i don't know
even half of it
oh you don't know half okay sensible
probably it's not fair to give you a
gotcha question then we were gonna
quiz you with a couple of countries but
we'll uh we'll maybe pass on that so
yeah well you've both of you have earned
your arrests thank you
so much nihal and andrew for a fantastic
match congratulations
uh to you nihal and best of luck in your
remaining matches and uh great play
andrew
so thanks to both of you uh you've
definitely earned
your rest yeah you've both acquired a
bunch of fans and nihal i think your
entire country can go to sleep right now
i'm sure that they're all
we did not lose any fans even though you
were pulling away so
i know it's one o'clock in india but uh
congratulations to
to the entire country of india because
you still have five
representatives in the chess kid junior
speed chess championship
all five are still alive so um thanks to
you both for an exciting match and i'm
sure that a lot of you
have gained a lot of people's respect
and we're gonna see a lot more of you
because
both of you guys i mean you're you're
still too young to
i don't know to do most things in life a
lot your future's uh very bright so
happy to have you guys thank you thanks
all right
well ladies and gentlemen as that
amazing match comes to an end we will
just
quickly remind you of the epic matches
still to come and uh tomorrow i believe
and i got this wrong once but i think we
have our generic ic against gukesh
two incredibly strong young indian
players that will be coming your way
same time
uh 12 eastern 9 a.m pacific
so that will be tomorrow a great way to
kick off the weekend
but what a match it was today an amazing
performance by nihal mike
uh any final thoughts on your end as we
just
forecast the predicted match in knee
hall one step closer to actually
fulfilling that
uh i'll just say i'm gonna go ahead and
ruin every chess fans complete weekend
by saying that sunday the next american
up is sam
sevien against i'm in tabatabe who's uh
a player who have only come to know in
the last years that's going to be an
amazing one as well
my weekend is ruined because i know i'm
going to watch both of these even if i'm
outside so
great stuff today very exciting five
minute section
um and uh our smarter chess predictions
that nihal sarin will be the predicted
winner
uh the funny thing about this prediction
is if you're a 60 favorite in each
match mathematically that does not
necessarily mean you'll win it all and
i'm not going to get into
the problem of statistics but knee hall
does survive and move on to the second
round
and he will play the winner of the
smirnoff radwani match so
i'm excited about all of the month to
come of all the other junior speed chess
championship players and
happy that chess kid is here to help
bring it to you absolutely
um well this was an incredible match
um i had just a blast
all of the sections were competitive new
hall taking it away
as the three-minute section began um
and as we come to an end just wanted to
say a very very big
shout out and thank you to the thousands
of people watching across platforms and
participating and cheering on the
respective players
uh and mike it was a pleasure to
commentate uh with you
as well the time just flew by thanks
daniel we will now perry's lagruska and
get ready for the match tomorrow
absolutely see everyone later stay safe
and see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you